Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There is a breathless hush in the close tonight, ten to make and the match to win, a bumping pitch and a blinding light, an hour to play and the last man in. And it's not for the sake of a ribboned coat, or the selfish hope of a season's fame,
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。今晚微风沉寂，球场屏息凝神，还差十分就能赢得比赛，凹凸不平的球场在刺眼的灯光下，离比赛结束还有一小时，最后一名击球手登场。这可不是为了什么饰带织成的外衣，也不是为了虚荣赛季中自私的奢望，
but his captain's hand on his shoulder smote play up play up and play the game oh tom holland i could see your lip curling in a metropolitan smear no i'm wiping away a manly tear so that is uh vitae lampada by sir henry newbold's the great poem of empire isn't it um and the great partbolt. The great poem of empire, isn't it? And one of the great poems of cricket. Much derided, I think, in the 21st century. But definitely a favourite poem in the Sandbrook household. I'm so glad to hear that, Dominic.
而是队长那只手重重地拍在他的肩上——顶住，顶住，打好这场比赛。哦，汤姆·霍兰德，我能看到你的嘴唇在一抹大都市的假笑中撇着。不，我是在擦拭男儿热泪。所以这首诗是……哦，亨利·纽博德爵士的《维塔·兰帕达》（Vita Lampada），帝国的伟大诗篇，不是吗？嗯，也是伟大的波尔特。帝国的伟大诗篇，不是吗？板球史上最伟大的诗篇之一。在21世纪，我认为这首诗遭到了很多嘲弄。但它绝对是桑德布鲁克家最喜欢的诗。听到这个我太高兴了，多米尼克。
Very much a favourite poem in the Holland household as well. I read it to my daughters every now and then. And do they laugh? They do. They do. So we're doing today's episodes on cricket which is obviously something i've been wanting to do for ages and ages and ages and the excuse for that is that um we this episode is going out midway through the first test match in the ashes series between england and australia And I'm aware that we will have lots of listeners
这也是霍兰德家非常喜欢的一首诗。我时不时会读给我的女儿们听。她们会笑吗？会的，会的。所以我们今天的节目是关于板球的，这显然是我一直、一直、一直都想做的一个主题，而借口是……嗯，这期节目播出时，正值英格兰和澳大利亚之间“灰烬杯”系列赛的首场测试赛进行到中途。我知道我们会有很多听众，
who will have no idea what we're going on about, who will have no interest in cricket, no knowledge of it at all. If you're an American, that's just babble. Yeah. So just by explanation, the Ashes is the kind of the oldest international ongoing contest in cricket between England and Australia.
他们完全不知道我们在说什么，对板球毫无兴趣，也完全不懂板球。如果你是个美国人，这简直就是胡言乱语。是的。所以简单解释一下，灰烬杯可以说是板球运动中最古老、持续至今的国际对抗赛，由英格兰和澳大利亚之间展开。
And it's the kind of centrepiece of every English cricket fan's obsession. But Iia and it's the kind of centerpiece of every english cricket fans obsession but i think also it's legitimate to look at cricket because i think you know just we did football didn't we uh we did the olympics and i think sport is a fascinating topic for historical inquiry whether you have any interest in it or not it is absolutely tom i mean as you know i'm not a great cricket fan but cricket has been an important part of english national identity and as that poem suggests because that poem goes on the later verses that have a scene in the sudan a battle in the sudan so cricket is kind of woven into britain's sense of the gatling jammed the
这也是每个英格兰板球迷痴迷的核心所在。不过，我认为探讨板球也是合理的，因为正如我们做过足球，嗯，做过奥运会一样，我认为体育是历史探究的一个迷人课题，不管你对它有没有兴趣。绝对是这样，汤姆。我的意思是，如你所知，我不是个板球大球迷，但板球一直是英国国家认同的重要组成部分。正如那首诗所暗示的——因为那首诗后面的诗节提到了苏丹的场景，苏丹的一场战役——所以板球已经编织进了英国人的意识之中。加特林机枪卡壳了……
gatling's jammed and the blood is seeping into it. It's brilliant. And a voice pipes up, play up, play up and play the game. It's presumably the same fellow who was playing crickets at Cheltenham. I think it's set at Cheltenham. Anyway, it's a reminder that also it's not just about England. Of course, it's also about empire. Oh, exactly.
加特林机枪卡壳了，鲜血渗了进去。这太精彩了。一个声音脱口而出：“顶住，顶住，打好这场比赛。”这大概就是那个在切尔滕纳姆打板球的家伙吧。我想背景设定在切尔滕纳姆。无论如何，这也提醒我们，这不仅关乎英格兰。当然，这也关乎帝国。哦，完全正确。
Exactly. Exactly. And the reason that, of course, people play crickets in India and Australia, as we will discover in this podcast, is because of the empire. But Will, I feel that even with your mighty mind and your great knowledge of cricket, we need a guest. Am I right? We do. And we need a top writer on cricket. I would say the top writer on cricket in England.
完全正确。完全正确。而且正如我们在这期播客中所发现的那样，人们在印度和澳大利亚打板球的原因，正是因为帝国。但是，威尔，我觉得即使以你强大的智商和渊博的板球知识，我们也需要一位嘉宾。我说的对吗？是的，我们需要。我们需要一位顶尖的板球作家。我可以说他是英格兰最顶尖的板球作家。
And it is my friend and teammate in the authors, the team that I play cricket with, John Houghton, who writes this fantastic blog called The Old Batsman. He co-wrote a film called Death of a Gentleman, which was an absolute evisceration of contemporary international cricket administrators. Absolutely brilliant film. And he wrote a book very modestly titled the meaning of cricket that's good yeah so john knows the meaning of cricket and john you're currently um you're
他就是我的朋友，也是我所在的板球队“作家队”的队友约翰·霍顿（John Houghton）。他写了一个非常棒的博客叫《老击球手》（The Old Batsman）。他联合编剧了一部名为《绅士之死》（Death of a Gentleman）的电影，对当代国际板球管理者进行了彻底的抨击。绝对是一部精彩绝伦的电影。他还写了一本书，书名非常谦逊，叫做《板球的意义》（The Meaning of Cricket）。这名字不错，是的。所以约翰懂板球的意义。约翰，你目前正在……
you're collaborating on a book with sir jeffrey boycott who is a name that will mean a great deal to people who have any interest in cricket um may will mean absolutely nothing to loads of our listeners so so that's that's that's something we've got to remember right the way through so um i mean just we've got a question here from judith downey is it possible for a conversation about cricket to hold my interest for the time span of a podcast and i mean i let i hope so i hope so because this is cricket is a really really fascinating mirror held up to all kinds of historical, cultural, social trends, isn't it? You would say so. Yes. I mean, it's a really it's a question that gets asked quite often.
你目前正在和杰弗里·博伊科特爵士（Sir Geoffrey Boycott）合作写一本书。这个名字对于任何对板球感兴趣的人来说都意义重大，但对于我们的许多听众来说，可能完全没有任何意义。所以这是我们在整个过程中必须牢记的一点。嗯，也就是说，我们这里有来自朱迪思·多尼的提问：“关于板球的对话能让我保持兴趣听完一整期播客吗？”我的意思是，我希望如此，我希望如此。因为板球真的是一面非常、非常迷人的镜子，映照出各种历史、文化和社会趋势，不是吗？你会这么说吧？是的。我的意思是，这是一个经常被提出的问题。
I think that question, why should I be interested in cricket? Because it has this kind of weirdly high bar to entry. You know, it's not that there's a there's a great story from Martin Amis when he was writing London Fields. And there's a character in it called Keith Talent, who's one of these sort of evil dwarf type characters. He plays darts. They're all evil dwarves in Martin Amis. He said he wanted, he knew the character had to, wanted to be involved in a sport. He had to play some sort of sport. And he first considered snooker,
我认为这个问题——“我为什么要对板球感兴趣？”——是因为它有一个奇怪的极高的入门门槛。你知道，马丁·艾米斯（Martin Amis）在写《伦敦菲尔兹》（London Fields）时有一个很棒的故事。里面有一个角色叫基思·塔尔能（Keith Talent），是那种邪恶的侏儒类角色之一。他玩飞镖。马丁·艾米斯笔下全都是邪恶的侏儒。他说他想要……他知道这个角色必须、想要参与一项运动。他必须玩某种运动。他首先考虑的是斯诺克，
but then he chose darts. And the reason he chose darts was that he said, you can tell anyone everything they need to know about darts in five minutes, right? Which is kind of cruel, but it's really true. There's no hinterland in darts. There's no kind of post-match technical analysis of a darts match you know you just chuck things at a board cricket is a sort of diametric opposite to that you know it's a game
但后来他选择了飞镖。他选择飞镖的原因是，他说，你可以在五分钟内把关于飞镖的所有必要知识告诉任何人，对吧？这听起来有点残忍，但确实如此。飞镖没有深厚的背景。没有那种赛后对飞镖比赛的技术分析，你知道的，你只是把东西扔向靶子而已。板球与此完全相反，你知道的，这是一项
that exists in the imagination and through time and if you don't have either of those things to give to it i i think this will be very difficult for you because it's archaic, it's arcane, it's hard to understand. And I've done a really good job in selling it. Yeah, you have. So are there any listeners left? Well, OK, so there's a question from Thad Will, question from the USA. Please explain, as you would for a child, how this game is played. We have no clue. Now, this is not a sports podcast, so we're not going to go into all that. But I would say at its most basic, actually, it's very simple.
存在于想象之中并历经时间的运动。如果你没有这两样东西投入其中，我想这会对你非常困难，因为它古老、晦涩、难以理解。而我真的很会推销它。是的，你确实很会推销。那么，还有听众留下吗？好吧，那么，有来自美国的萨德·威尔（Thad Will）的提问：请像给小孩子解释一样，解释一下这项运动是怎么玩的。我们完全摸不头脑。现在，这不是一个体育播客，所以我们不会深入探讨所有这些。但我想说，最基本的其实非常简单：
It's a bloke chucking a ball and somebody tries to hit it. Trying to hit it, yes. I mean, people sort of... And that's, you know, it could be baseball. I mean, in a way, it's kind of hockey and golf. I mean, they all kind of... Yeah. It's a stick and you try and hit a ball.
就是一个家伙把球扔过来，然后有人试图击打它。试图击打它，是的。我的意思是，人们有点……而且，你知道，这可能就像棒球。从某种程度上说，它有点像曲棍球和高尔夫。我的意思是，它们都有点……是的。就是一根棍子，然后你试着击打一个球。
So if we're looking at where cricket comes from, how it originates, how it emerges in England when it it does where does cricket begin and this is a much mythologized issue is it not it really is yes i i even saw a quote today from from uh john major who is a cricket obsessive former prime minister historian himself historian he wrote a very good good book about the history of cricket. And he said it's a bit like searching for the Holy Grail. You will never find it. You will never find the origins of cricket. WG, cricket's most famous player, he claimed it originated from coits.
所以，如果我们探究板球来自哪里，它是如何起源的，它在英格兰是如何出现的——当它出现时，板球到底是在哪里开始的？这是一个被高度神话化的问题，不是吗？确实是这样，是的。我甚至今天还看到约翰·梅杰（John Major）的一句名言——他是一位板球狂热分子、前首相，同时也是一位历史学家，他写过一本关于板球历史的非常好的书。他说，这有点像寻找圣杯。你永远找不到它。你永远找不到板球的起源。WG（板球史上最著名的球员）声称它起源于抛铁饼（coits）。
But what century do you think we're talking about? 16th, 17th, 18th? Well, Dominic... Oh, don't tell me to go back even further. Well, shall I tell you what the... He's been dying to tell this story. What an Armenian professor, Dr. Abraham Terrian, thinks it came from,
但是你认为我们谈论的是哪个世纪？16世纪、17世纪还是18世纪？嗯，多米尼克……哦，别告诉我要追溯到更早。好吧，我要不要告诉你……他一直憋着想讲这个故事。一位亚美尼亚教授亚伯拉罕·特里安博士（Dr. Abraham Terrian）认为它源于什么，
and who the first person to play it was. No, don't. Go on, go on. Is it a big name? Is it an Armenian king? who the first person to play it was? No, don't. I'm going to tell you. Go on, go on. Do you know who it was? There you are. Is it a big name? It is a big name. Is it an Armenian king? No, it's...
以及谁是第一个玩它的人？不，别说。说吧，说吧。这是个大人物吗？是个亚美尼亚国王吗？谁是第一个玩它的人？不，别说。我要告诉你。说吧，说吧。你知道是谁吗？给你。是个大人物吗？确实是个大人物。是个亚美尼亚国王吗？不，它是……
Is it R2V2? No, Dominic, it's Jesus. Jesus played cricket. So he found... Based on what? He found in the manuscript library of the Armenian Patriarchate of Jerusalem... Yeah.
是R2D2吗？不，多米尼克，是耶稣。耶稣打过板球。所以他发现……基于什么？他在耶路撒冷亚美尼亚牧首的手稿图书馆里发现了……是的。
...an 8th century copy of a much earlier gospel which described the infancy of Jesus. And in this gospel, Jesus is described as playing something faintly similar to cricket, i.e. people throwing balls and he's hitting it. And the catch is that Jesus, when he chases the ball,
……一本8世纪的更早期福音书的抄本，其中描述了耶稣的童年。在这本福音书里，描述了耶稣在玩某种隐约类似于板球的游戏，也就是人们扔球而他在击打。关键在于，耶稣在追球时，
can run onto the sea. Thereby. Wow. Did we not discuss in a previous podcast about how Piltdown Man had a cricket bat or something like that? An ancient cricket bat? Yes. So that's the kind of classic example of the way in which people can kind of back project and create myths around it. I mean, I think obviously Jesus didn't play cricket.
可以跑到海面上。因此。哇。我们难道没有在之前的播客中讨论过皮尔当人（Piltdown Man）有一根板球棒或类似的东西吗？古代板球棒？是的。所以这正是人们如何追溯过去并围绕它创造神话的典型例子。我的意思是，显然耶稣没有打过板球，
Obviously this wasn't cricket. And there have been all kinds of attempts to kind of trace its origins beyond England. So there's... Surely people are now claiming it's invented in China or something. Are they? Well, Belgium is very popular.
显然这不是板球。而且人们曾有过各种各样的尝试，试图将其起源追溯到英格兰之外。所以有……难道现在有人声称它是中国或什么地方发明的吗？是吗？嗯，比利时非常受欢迎。
Belgium? Criquet. Right. Yeah. Tintin was a great cricketer. Yeah. And there's... And Hercule Poirot.
比利时？Criquet。对。丁丁是个伟大的板球运动员。还有赫尔克里·波洛（Hercule Poirot）。
An eighth century monk saw a sport with a bat and ball being played in Florence. Okay. There's an 8th century monk saw a sport with a bat and ball being played in Florence. Okay. There's a 12th century poet says that young men in England enjoy a game called cricks. And there's a clerk in the reign of Edward I who complained that the Prince of Wales, so future Edward II, was passionate about a game called CREAG. Okay. They sound very implausible to me, to be honest.
一个8世纪的僧侣看到一项挥舞球棒和球的运动在佛罗伦萨进行。好吧。一个8世纪的僧侣看到一项挥舞球棒和球的运动在佛罗伦萨进行。好吧。一个12世纪的诗人说，英格兰的年轻人喜欢一种叫做“克里克斯”（cricks）的游戏。爱德华一世统治时期的一个职员抱怨说，威尔士亲王（即后来的爱德华二世）对一种叫做“克里格”（CREAG）的游戏充满热情。好吧。说实话，听起来非常不可信。
Yeah, I think they are implausible. But John, are people playing cricket, let's say, in the Civil War? Well, again, yes. Yes, you would say a recognisable version of what becomes cricket, yes. But cricket, you know, it's one of those things it has many roots many origins it had many forms it wasn't really and i suppose until grace came along and you know his his first season was in 1864 a very kind of significant time for cricket because it was the first season that uh overarm bowling was legalized for example it was the it was the first season that over-armed bowling was legalised, for example. It was the year the first Wisden came out.
是的，我认为它们并不可信。但是，约翰，人们在内战期间就在打板球了吗？嗯，同样是的。是的，你会说这是一种可以辨认的板球版本，是的。但是板球，你知道的，它是那种有很多根源、很多起源、很多形式的东西。直到格雷斯（Grace）出现——你知道，他的第一个赛季是在1864年，这对板球来说是一个非常重要的时期，因为那是……例如，第一年将“手腕过肩投球”（overarm bowling）合法化，那是……例如，手腕过肩投球被合法化的第一年。那也是第一本《威斯顿板球年鉴》（Wisden）出版的年份。
So Wisden is the almanac that comes out and gives you all the details every year. You know, one of cricket's great hinterlands is its statistical meaning and the way it's recorded. And so at that point, cricket was recognisably cricket. Before then, there'd been lots of different versions of cricket, so small-sided games. You had famous games where you'd have a farmer and his dog playing against a bloke up the road in the village, and they'd be playing a version of cricket.
所以《威斯顿》是每年出版并提供所有详细数据的年鉴。你知道，板球伟大的背景之一就是它的统计意义以及它的记录方式。所以从那时起，板球就可以被认为真正是板球了。在此之前，有许多不同版本的板球，比如小型对抗赛。你听说过著名的比赛，一个农夫和他的狗在村里和路边的某个人对打，他们打的就是某种版本的板球。
Generally, in those tales, one of them drops down dead because the dog is a brilliant fielder and no one can score a run, you know. So there's lots of those kind of origin style myths. But the amazing thing, I think, I suppose the thing to say is the root of the game as we know it would probably come from two places. And I would say one of them is the measurement of the pitch, of the area of ground that it's played on. And the measure of a cricket pitch is 22 yards. And when is that decided? And that comes from Thomas Gunter's chain, which you may or may not have heard of.
通常在这些故事中，其中一个人会突然倒地身亡，因为那只狗是个绝佳的野手，谁也无法得分，你知道的。所以有很多这种起源风格的神话。但令人惊叹的是，我想，或许应该说，我们所知道的这项运动的根源可能来自两个地方。我会说其中之一就是对球场的测量，也就是进行比赛的场地面积的测量。板球场的标准长度是22码。这是什么时候决定的？这来自于托马斯·冈特（Thomas Gunter）的测地链，你可能听说过，也可能没听说过。
It was a way of measuring land. He came up with a way of measuring land using a physical chain that was 66 links or 22 yards long. And when was that? And that was used as the base of the length of the field. I think Gunter's chain, I'd have to look it up. I'd have to look it up. I'm not a historian who immediately recalls the dates. I will look it up for you now.
这是一种测量土地的方法。他想出了一种用实体链来测量土地的方法，这条链有66个链环或22码长。那是什么时候？这被用作球场长度的基础。我想冈特链……我得查一下。我得查一下。我不是那种能立刻回想起日期的历史学家。我现在就为你查一下。
This is brilliant. This is live action. Live research. Live research. Live research. But the amazing thing is it has never changed. It's never changed. Everyone being able to lay down this chain and say that's how long a pitch is. I've looked it up.
这太棒了。这是现场直播。现场研究。现场研究。现场研究。但神奇的是，它从未改变过。从未改变过。每个人都能铺下这条链，然后说这就是球场的长度。我查过了。
It's 1620. 1620. So the amazing thing about 22 yards is that it has contained the whole game ever since, which is an astonishing thing. And anyone can play on it, you know, whether you're five foot three, a real little short ass, whether you're six foot ten, you can compete equally on this distance. And unlike sort of golf courses or tennis balls or anything like that, it's never changed. So, John, people who are playing it. So England is a very, very rural society at this point. The town is pretty small. I mean, they're expanding. So you obviously need quite a lot of space, but there is a lot of space. So basically it's a village game rather than a town game, is it? Before Victorians made it what we know as cricket today, it would be tiny little games played in hamlets and villages. It was a country sport for working class people.
是1620年。1620年。所以22码神奇的地方在于，从那以后它就承载了整场比赛，这是一件了不起的事情。而且任何人都可以打，你知道的，不管你身高五尺三寸（矮个子），还是身高六尺十寸，你都可以在这个距离上平等竞技。不像高尔夫球场或网球或诸如此类的东西，它从未改变过。所以，约翰，关于打球的人。所以英格兰当时是一个非常、非常偏远的乡村社会。城镇相当小。我的意思是，它们在扩张。所以你显然需要相当大的空间，但那里确实有很多空间。所以基本上这是一项乡村运动，而不是城镇运动，是吗？在维多利亚时代的人把它变成我们今天所知的板球之前，它是由在小村庄里进行的极小规模的比赛组成的。这是为工人阶级准备的乡村运动。
It wasn't this thing that it would become. And Puritans are actually complaining, aren't they, if people are playing it? Yeah, I mean, there's sort of around where I live, which is on the Surrey-Hampshire borders, there's a lot of this origin stories of the game. There's a village called Recklesham, who I did play cricket for in my youth. And there was a story that Recklesham, it's had something like five pubs within its village boundaries
它还不是后来那种庞然大物。清真寺的人实际上在抱怨，不是吗，如果人们在玩的话？是的，我的意思是，在我住的地方附近，也就是萨里郡和汉普郡的边界上，有很多关于这项运动起源的故事。有一个叫雷克尔舍姆（Recklesham）的村庄，我年轻时曾为他们打过板球。有个故事说，雷克尔舍姆村界内有大约五家酒吧，
and was a kind of a place known for bad behaviour on a Sunday. People would go to the pubs on a Sunday and then play cricket. And cricket was this kind of, you know, almost a roguish, terrible thing to do. So at that point, people are playing just on their one day off, basically,
是一个以星期天行为不端而闻名的地方。人们星期天去酒吧，然后打板球。板球成了那种……几乎是一种无赖的、可怕的消遣。所以当时人们基本上只在他们唯一的一天假里玩，
are they? I mean, there aren't multi-day games. I mean, because they're working in the fields and stuff. Yeah. And also the game, although it had its 22 yards, it couldn't go on for long enough. It was too difficult to play in those days. I mean, the reason cricket lasts for a long time now is that people have got very good at it.
是吗？我的意思是，没有多日赛。因为他们要在田里干活之类的。是的，而且这项运动尽管有22码的规定，但它当时无法持续足够长的时间。那时候玩起来太难了。我的意思是，现在板球之所以能持续很长时间，是因为人们已经变得非常擅长它了。
Before then, I mean, you know, the games would be quite low scoring and quite quick. Because the pitches are kind of rough. The pitches don't exist. They're just in the middle of a field. I mean, there used to be cricket starts. Most cricket matches start now with the toss of a coin. So the two teams can decide who's going to bat and who's going to bowl. Very, very early, the winner of the toss got to decide where the pitch would be.
在那之前，我的意思是，你知道，比赛的得分会很低，而且结束得很快。因为球场有点粗糙。球场根本不存在。它们只是在田野的正中央。我的意思是，以前板球的开局……现在大多数板球比赛都是通过掷硬币开始的。这样两支球队就可以决定谁先击球，谁先投球。在非常非常早期的时候，掷硬币赢的人可以决定球场设在哪里。
That's good. That's great. So they would walk into a field and toss a coin and then the winning captain could select where in the field he would put the pitch. And we've got a question from Nathan Hogg, which actually we should ask. So Nathan Hogg says, the name, where did cricket get its name from? Because it is kind of a weird name. I mean, football makes sense. Rugby, obviously, because it's the school.
这很棒。太棒了。所以他们会走进一片田野，掷硬币，然后获胜的队长就可以选择他把球场设在田野的哪个位置。我们有一个来自内森·霍格（Nathan Hogg）的问题，其实我们应该问一下。内森·霍格说：这个名字，板球的名字是从哪里来的？因为它确实是个奇怪的名字。我的意思是，足球的名字说得通。橄榄球（Rugby）显然是因为那个学校。
But why cricket? Yes, I mean, all these things like cricks kriag and coits was wg's suggestion yeah who knows i don't know and that is part of the mystery of it yeah yeah it's and i mean it again like football football in a way you know all kinds of different versions of football were played through the middle ages right the way up to the victorian period and you keep talking about the victorian period that this is where it gets regularized this is where laws get introduced where kind of standardization happens but before that again you're kind of saying that there are all these different versions of it that have been played in different villages in different counties
但为什么叫板球（cricket）？是的，我的意思是，所有这些诸如cricks、kriag和coits之类的东西，都是WG的建议。谁知道呢，我不知道。这也是它神秘感的一部分。是的，是的。而且它……我的意思是，再次像足球一样，你知道，从中世纪一直到维多利亚时期，人们一直在踢各种不同版本的足球。你一直在谈论维多利亚时期，说这是它被规范化的地方，这是引入规则、实现标准化的地方。但在那之前，你再次提到，在不同的村庄、不同的郡，人们一直在玩所有这些不同版本的游戏……
um i mean is that right that basically it's it's it's in the south to begin with but then also it starts to spread up to the up to to Yorkshire and places like that? Well, here we go. I mean, we kind of tend to think of it as having begun in the south because that's where it's first recorded. I mean, in deepest Hampshire, there's a village called Hambledon, which is considered to be the cradle of the game. There's a pitch there called Broadhapenny Down, and that's where the game's thought to have started. But the only reason people think it started there is because that was where it was first written down, really. So the son of the publican, obviously, the pitch was opposite a pub. There's a great tie always between cricket and alcohol, certainly in England, cricket
我的意思是，这是真的吗？基本上，它一开始是在南方，但随后也开始向北蔓延到约克郡之类的地方？好吧，这里我们要说的是……我们倾向于认为它起源于南方，因为那是它最早被记录下来的地方。我的意思是，在汉普郡腹地，有一个叫汉布尔顿（Hambledon）的村庄，被认为是这项运动的发源地。那里有一个叫布罗德哈珀尼唐（Broadhapenny Down）的球场，人们认为比赛就是从那里开始的。但人们认为它从那里开始的唯一原因，是因为那是它最早被文字记录下来的地方。所以，酒吧老板的儿子——显然球场就在酒吧对面。板球和酒精之间一直有着巨大的联系，当然在英格兰，板球
and drinking, both amongst the players and the spectators. But so the son of the publican, John Niren, began to write down the stories of the cricketers he'd seen in his youth. He called it Cricketers of Our Time. And those were the first cricketers we really know about and the first matches we really know about in any depth. And so people tend to think, well, that's where the game started. Whether there was another village in Yorkshire where exactly the same thing was happening, but no one wrote it down. Who knows? And what's interesting then is that you've got this kind of rural game and it's played among people who are not necessarily upper class at all. I mean, often labourers, the opposite of it. But at the same time, certainly in the 18th century you're starting to get very very posh people i mean including even the prince of wales starting to become obsessed by it too and we've
和喝酒总是联系在一起，无论是在球员还是观众当中。所以酒吧老板的儿子约翰·尼伦（John Niren）开始写下他在年轻时见过的板球运动员的故事。他称之为《我们时代的板球运动员》（Criceters of Our Time）。这些是我们真正了解的第一代板球运动员，也是我们真正深入了解的第一场比赛。因此人们往往会想，哦，这就是这项运动的发源地。至于约克郡是否也有一个村庄发生着完全相同的事情，只是没有人把它写下来？谁知道呢。有趣的是，你拥有这种乡村游戏，而且它是在那些不一定是上流社会的人当中进行的。我的意思是，通常是体力劳动者，恰恰相反。但与此同时，肯定在18世纪，你开始看到非常非常富有的人，甚至包括威尔士亲王也开始对它着迷。我们有一个问题来自……
got a question from um from dan jackson friend of the show northumbrian would you agree that cricket is arguably the least class-based sport in england played and watched by everyone certainly in comparison to football and rugby i mean i, I guess maybe that's changed with football now. But that sense that cricket is a sport that is played both by agricultural labourers and by dukes does make it kind of distinctive, doesn't it? Well, it does. Yeah. I mean, I think it goes back to this notion of time again. You know, there were huge chunks of time that the aristocracy and the wealthier men had to fill in. I mean, what did you do all day? If you were rich, what did you do all day?
来自丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson），节目之友、诺森布里亚人：“你是否同意，板球可以说是英格兰阶级色彩最淡的运动，每个人都在玩，每个人都在看，当然与足球和橄榄球相比？”我的意思是，我想现在足球可能已经变了。但板球既能被农业劳动力玩，又能被公爵们玩的这种感觉，确实让它显得与众不同，不是吗？嗯，确实如此。是的。我的意思是，我认为这又回到了关于时间的观念上。你知道，贵族和富有的人有大量的时间需要消磨。我的意思是，你一整天都在干什么？如果你很有钱，你一整天都在干什么？
You had to do something. So cricket kind of becomes tied up with other things like hunting and boxing. There was a great rage for the gentlemen to be able to box at one point, fighting in the streets. It becomes tied up with these other leisure pursuits. There's something great rage for the gentleman to be able to box at one point, you know, fighting in the streets. All of these, it becomes tied up with these other leisure pursuits. There's something to do. Horse racing, you know, you had to fill your time. So you had these kind of patrons emerging who would go and literally patronise the good cricketers in their area.
你总得做点什么。所以板球开始与打猎和拳击等其他事情交织在一起。有一段时间，绅士们非常流行拳击，在街头打架。它与这些其他的休闲消遣交织在一起。有一段时间，绅士们非常流行拳击，你知道，在街头打架。所有这些，它与这些其他的休闲消遣交织在一起。总得做点什么。赛马，你知道，你必须打发时间。所以你有了这些新兴的赞助商，他们会去亲自赞助他们当地优秀的板球运动员。
And also it lends itself to gambling, doesn't it? Very much. And it lends itself to a day out. I mean, it's a relatively slow moving sport you can stand there and have a chat with people and turn around and not much has happened in the meantime you probably haven't missed anything um and it just became a kind of very very nice day out really a summer's day out so at what point if you had to i i know you the records are very hazy and it's all kind of in the murk of time but if you had to, I know the records are very hazy and it's all kind of in the murk of time,
而且它也很适合赌博，不是吗？非常适合。而且它很适合作为一天的外出消遣。我的意思是，这是一项相对节奏缓慢的运动，你可以站在那里和人们聊天，转过身去，期间并没有发生太多事情，你大概什么也没有错过，嗯，它真的变成了一种非常非常愉快的日常外出消遣，夏日外出消遣。那么在什么时间，如果你必须——我知道记录非常模糊，一切都隐藏在时间的迷雾中，但如果你必须……我知道记录非常模糊，一切都隐藏在时间的迷雾中，
but if you had to pinpoint a time when people went to watch cricket. Oh, that's a good one, yeah. When are people going in sort of decent numbers, i.e. not just to watch their family member play, but to watch a game? Well, I mean, cricket has a great, has always had a long ongoing relationship with novelty.
但如果你必须指出一个人们开始去看板球的时间点……哦，这是一个好问题，是的。人们是在什么时候以相当可观的数量去观看的？也就是说，不仅仅是为了看他们的家庭成员比赛，而是为了观看一场比赛？嗯，我的意思是，板球有着伟大且一直持续的新奇事物情结。
It loves novelty. It loves to reinvent itself. It has this sort of pastoral image as something unchanging. In fact, it's a game that is constantly reinventing itself. So as the sort of, I suppose you'd say the Regency era, the fancy, as they start to go to games to fill in time, they want these kind of novelty events to happen that they can watch. So you had games, certainly in the Regency era,
它热爱新鲜事物。它热爱自我重塑。它有一种历久弥新的田园牧歌形象。事实上，这是一项不断自我重塑的运动。所以随着……我想你可以说是摄政时期，那些追求时髦的人开始去看比赛来打发时间，他们希望看到这些新奇的活动发生来供他们观赏。所以你确实有比赛，当然是在摄政时期，
after the Napoleonic Wars, you had games where you'd have a team of men with one arm against a team of men with one leg. That sounds brilliant. How could the men with one leg run? I mean, that's all part of the fun of it. And it was, it was called something like a grotesque spectacle or something,
拿破仑战争之后，你会有这样的比赛：一队独臂的人对阵一队独腿的人。听起来太棒了。独腿的人怎么跑步？我的意思是，这正是其中的乐趣所在。它被称为诸如“怪诞奇观”之类的东西，
but they were all veterans of it. They were mostly guys living in, you know, in, I suppose, arms, accommodation given to ex-Navy personnel. The aptly named Arms Houses. Arms Houses, yeah. There's a really famous scorecard, and I've always wondered whether this was where they got the name from, where the number 11 for the one-legged team was called Baldrick.
但他们全都是退伍老兵。他们大多是住在……我想是为前海军人员提供的荣军院住所里的家伙。恰如其名，叫“荣军院”（Arms Houses）。荣军院，是的。有一张非常著名的记分卡，我一直想知道他们是不是从这里得名的，独腿队的第11号队员名叫巴尔德里克（Baldrick）。
Yeah, seriously. And he was run out twice for Nought. And they were given, like, the game lasted for two days and overnight they were fed on ale and meat and all of this tremendous, impossible to digest stuff. And it just became, and then you had games like married versus single. You had games like 13 stone versus under 13 games with like a 13 stone versus oh you know under 13 stone they should do more of that they're definitely in a way in a way that is what they do that in a way that you know with the reinvention of cricket
是的，说真的。他两次因“零分”而被跑出局（run out）。他们得到的待遇是，比赛持续两天，夜里他们被喂以麦芽酒、肉和所有这些极其难以消化的东西。然后它就变成……然后你有了诸如“已婚对单身”之类的比赛。你有了诸如13英石对13英石以下的比赛……像13英石对——哦，你知道的，13英石以下。他们应该多做点那种比赛。他们绝对……从某种程度上说，这就是他们在做的……通过板球的重塑，
with new formats like 2020 cricket and those sort of things that's the modern equivalent of what that was well so there's a really interesting question here from david davis uh who says i often hear complaints that modern cricket is dumbing down the great games tradition so talking about 2020 whatever however i do feel the 2020 the ipl gambling money etc is much closer to its georgian roots in the public school victorian morality of early 20th century cricket do you agree so that that's focusing in on what is quite an interesting pivot in the history of cricket that you you do have this kind of buccaneering Regency sense where they're all one-legged, gambling on it, all that kind of stuff and getting drunk and all kinds of things. And then with the Victorian period, that's where you start to get ideas of it not being cricket. Yes.
引入诸如二十20板球（2020 cricket）之类的新赛制，这正是当年那种做法的现代版。好吧，这里有一个来自大卫·戴维斯（David Davis）的非常有趣的问题，他说：“我经常听到抱怨说现代板球正在弱智化这项伟大游戏的传统——谈论二十20等等。然而，我确实觉得二十20、IPL、赌博资金等东西，比20世纪初公立学校维多利亚式道德观念更接近它的乔治王时代根源。你同意吗？”所以这就聚焦于板球历史上的一个相当有趣的转折点，你确实拥有那种海盗式的摄政时期风格，在那里他们都是独腿的，在上面赌博，诸如此类的事情，喝得酩酊大醉。然后到了维多利亚时期，你开始有了这不是板球（it's not cricket）的想法。是的。
Am I ever simplifying? No, I don't think so. I think the Victorians were the ones who imposed this moral sense on the game. So before the Victorians did that, it was a game for rogues. There was a lot of cheating. There was a lot of gambling. There was a lot of match fixing. And so the Victorians came along and I suppose with their general culture thought, well, we can't have that. Actually, here's a game that can be a vision of England. And as the Victorians do that, you get this great star emerging, the first famous cricketer really in WG Grace.
我是不是把问题过分简单化了？不，我不这么认为。我认为维多利亚时代的人是将这种道德感强加到这项运动中的人。所以在维多利亚人这样做之前，这是一项无赖的游戏。有很多作弊。有很多赌博。有很多打假球。所以维多利亚时代的人来了，我想带着他们普遍的文化，心想：“嗯，我们不能那样。实际上，这里有一项可以成为英格兰愿景的运动。”随着维多利亚人这样做，你迎来了第一位真正伟大的板球明星WG·格雷斯（WG Grace）。
And he comes along because he's a huge man with a big beard. And maybe even people who know nothing about cricket perhaps may have a sense of him well this is the interesting thing is that he is probably still today more famous than some of the people in the england cricket team and this is this is the resonance his image is kind of carried with it down the years john you said i mean you say um that he's the most famous cricketer i mean in a way he's the most famous person in victorian england he's the first great celebrity is he is he is he's the most famous cricketer. I mean, in a way, he's the most famous person. In Victorian England. He's the first great celebrity, isn't he? He is. He is. He's the first celebrity. And of course it goes to his head and to his gut.
他之所以脱颖而出，是因为他是一个身材魁梧、留着大胡子的男子。也许甚至连那些对板球一无所知的人也可能对他有所耳闻。这就是有趣的地方：今天他可能仍然比英格兰板球队的一些成员还要出名，这就是他的形象历经岁月流传下来的共鸣。约翰，你刚才说……你的意思是……他是最著名的板球运动员。从某种程度上说，他是维多利亚时代英格兰最有名的人。他是第一个伟大的名人，他是……他是最著名的板球运动员。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，他是最有名的人。在维多利亚时代英格兰。他是第一个伟大的名人，不是吗？他是。他是。他是第一位名人。当然，这冲昏了他的头脑，也填满了他的肚子。
I mean, he comes from a small village called Downend outside of Bristol. He's got a very high-pitched, squeaky voice. Like a Neanderthal. Like a Neanderthal, yes. He's thought of as, you know, a slight figure of fun. They look down their noses at him. But he is a genius at this game.
我的意思是，他来自布里斯托尔郊外一个叫唐恩德（Downend）的小村庄。他有着非常高亢、刺耳的声音。像个尼安德特人。像个尼安德特人，是的。他被认为是一个……有点可笑的人物。他们看不起他。但他在这个游戏里是个天才。
He's a huge, I mean, he's a huge man. First of all, he's sort of six foot three. He gets bigger and bigger as he eats and drinks more and more and becomes more of a star. But you compare this to Victoria in England when everyone was a short ass. You know, it would be like us looking at Tyson Fury, you know, the enormous man with a big beard.
他是个大块头，我的意思是，他是个身材高大的人。首先，他身高约六尺三寸。随着他吃得越多、喝得越多、名气越来越大，他的体型也变得越来越大。但你把这与每个人都是矮个子的维多利亚时代英格兰相比。你知道，这就好比我们看着泰森·富里（Tyson Fury），那个留着大胡子的庞然大物。
Even if you see pictures of him when he was 18 and made his sort of fabulous breakthrough season in 1866, when he plays the innings that comes to define modern cricket, the innings that people often say, if you could see one innings from cricket history, one moment, what would it be? Well, it would be WG as an 18-year-old at the Oval scoring 224 against Surrey for All England
即使你看到他18岁时的照片，他在18世纪60年代（译者注：原文如此，实际为19世纪）迎来了他传奇般的突破赛季，当时他打出了一场定义了现代板球的比赛，人们经常说：如果你能从板球历史中看到一场比赛、一个时刻，那会是什么？好吧，那将会是18岁的WG在奥瓦尔球场（Oval）代表全英格兰对阵萨里郡时得到224分。
because this innings changes everything. And he does it over two days. And why does it change everything? Well, he does it over two days. And until WG came along the the contest between bat and ball which is the the pivotal contest in cricket was always won by the ball there was a wg himself said two days yeah wg himself said um uh it was it was thought that if the bowling was good uh all the batsman could do nothing about it.
因为这场比赛改变了一切。而且他花了整整两天时间完成。为什么它改变了一切？嗯，他花了整整两天时间。在WG出现之前，蝙蝠与球之间的较量——这是板球运动中至关重要的较量——总是由球占上风。WG自己说过……两天，是的。WG自己曾说过……嗯，人们曾认为，如果投球很好，击球手就无能为力了。
All he could do would keep it out. Well, I resolved to challenge that theory. And he begins with his great size and strength, whacking the ball in the air over the field as it becomes spectacular and amazing. And what he does really is he imagines a future. He changes the mindset of the game. And this is how the game always changes with an act of imagination. And he's the first one to do that. And the great thing is, this is how much of an athlete he was
他能做的只是把球挡出去。好吧，我决心挑战这个理论。他凭借自己巨大的体型和力量，将球高高击打过场内，这变得蔚为壮观和惊人。他真正做的是，他想象了一个未来。他改变了这项运动的心态。而这项运动总是通过想象力的行为来改变的。他是第一个这样的人。最棒的是，这就是他作为一个运动员的水平。
before he became the big guy. A man of size. In between this two-day innings in the evening, he goes from the oval to Crystal Palace and wins the 420-yard hurdles. That is so brilliant. In his pink racing knickerbock hurdles. That is so brilliant. In his pink racing knickerbockers. That's so Victorian behaviour. So he was a bit of a lad, you know, but obviously a star.
在这次为期两天的比赛的某个傍晚，他从奥瓦尔球场前往水晶宫（Crystal Palace），赢得了420码栏架赛的冠军。这太棒了。穿着他的粉红色赛跑马裤……栏架赛。这太棒了。穿着他的粉红色赛跑马裤。这真是非常维多利亚式的行为。所以他当时有点像个浪荡公子，你知道的，但显然是个明星。
And as he becomes bigger and bigger, and, you know, obviously the railways come along, the newspapers come along, and all of a sudden he can go around the country. He can play cricket all around the country. People can see him. When he gets to Australia for the first time, the docks at Melbourne are aligned with people because they just want to see him.
随着他的体型越来越大，而且，你知道的，铁路出现了，报纸出现了，突然之间他可以走遍全国。他可以在全国各地打板球。人们可以看到他。当他第一次抵达澳大利亚时，墨尔本的码头上挤满了人，因为他们只是想亲眼看看他。
And he gets sponsored, doesn't he? He gets sponsored by Coleman's Mustard. He did get sponsored. So at that point, you have record-keeping of games. Yeah, yeah. So people know what his score is. You have crowds going. And do you have an organised national competition of any kind?
而且他得到了赞助，不是吗？他得到了科尔曼芥末（Coleman's Mustard）的赞助。他确实得到了赞助。所以从那时起，你有了比赛的记录保存。是的，是的。所以人们知道他的得分是多少。你有了蜂拥而至的观众。那么你有没有任何形式的组织化全国比赛呢？
Yeah, I mean, that is emerging at exactly the same time. There isn't international cricket when WG comes along, but there is county cricket. Now, for those listening outside England, I suppose you define as county. I mean, Tom will give you chapter and verse on what is a county and what is a region and all of that stuff because he yearns for the return of Wessex. But essentially, I think of it like a state or, you know, your local. Now, why?
是的，我的意思是，那正是在同一时期兴起的。当WG出现时，还没有国际板球，但有郡级板球（county cricket）。现在，对于那些在英格兰以外听节目的听众，我想你会将“郡”定义为……我的意思是，汤姆会给你详细讲解什么是郡、什么是地区以及所有这些东西，因为他渴望威塞克斯（Wessex）的复辟。但基本上，我认为它就像一个州，或者，你知道的，你的地方。现在，为什么？
That's a puzzle to me because football and rugby, I mean, they have clubs in big towns. So, you know, in in football it's obviously Manchester United or Wolves or whoever in rugby well there's a shut up Wolverhampton Wanderers is one of the founder members of the football league I'll have you know right um it's the one that comes to everyone's mind of course it is of course it's got such a iconic history and a emblematic badge I don't know what you're talking about um rugby you know bristol bath i mean they're all big okay their strength is in the west country but it's in towns or in leicester or gloucester or whatever why is cricket county why isn't it cities yeah well i
这对我来说是个谜，因为足球和橄榄球，我的意思是，它们在各大城镇都有俱乐部。所以，你知道，在足球中，显然是曼联或狼队（Wolves）或随便什么人。在橄榄球中，嗯，那里有一个……闭嘴！伍尔弗汉普顿流浪者队（Wolverhampton Wanderers）是足球联盟的创始成员之一，我要你知道这一点！对，嗯，那是每个人脑海中最先浮现的俱乐部，当然是的，当然，它有着如此标志性的历史和具有象征意义的队徽。我不知道你在说什么。嗯……橄榄球，你知道，布里斯托尔、巴斯（Bath），我的意思是，它们都很大。好吧，它们的实力在西南部，但它们都在城镇里，或者在莱斯特、格洛斯特或随便什么地方。为什么板球是以“郡”为单位的？为什么不是按城市？是的，嗯……
think i think just because it's slightly earlier it's very slightly earlier and and counties were big enough to to generate 11 or 22 or however many men you needed to form a team. Right. So, I mean, I would guess that's the reason. And because of the rural roots, I suppose. Yeah, maybe the rural roots as well, yeah. But it just happened slightly earlier than those, you know, those football clubs you're talking about were, what, 1870, 1880?
我想，我想这只是因为它稍微早一点。它稍微早一点，而且郡的规模足够大，可以产生11人、22人或你需要组成一个团队所需的任意多的人。对。所以，我的意思是，我猜这就是原因。而且我想是因为乡村根源。是的，也许也有乡村根源，是的。但它发生的时间比那些你所说的足球俱乐部稍微早一点，那些俱乐部是什么时候？18世纪70年代、18世纪80年代？
Yeah. Some of the top clubs, I 1877 Tom so so the the counties in cricket are very slightly you know 20 or 30 years earlier than that so John you um you mentioned Australia and in after the break we should look at the kind of the spread of cricket around the world but just one last thing on Victorian cricket and its growth. The phrase, it's not cricket, the kind of sentiments that were expressed in the poem with which Dominic opened this episode. The idea that playing cricket is somehow morally improving, that it's about sportsmanship, that it's about fair play. That it has a moral dimension. Yeah. That is not a feature of the game when you've got all these kind of snuff-taking rakes who are gambling and paying one-legged men and so on.
是的。顶级俱乐部中的一些，18世纪77年（译者注：原文如此），汤姆。所以板球中的“郡”比那稍微早一点，早了20或30年。所以，约翰，你提到了澳大利亚。中场休息后，我们将探讨板球在世界各地的传播。但关于维多利亚时期的板球及其发展，还有最后一件事。那句话——“这不是板球”（it's not cricket），也就是多米尼克在节目开头的诗中所表达的那种情感。打板球在某种程度上具有道德提升作用，它关乎体育精神，关乎公平竞争。它具有道德维度。是的。当你有所有这些赌博、收买独腿人等等的吸鼻烟的浪荡公子时，这不是这项运动的特征。
Where does this idea that, you know, you play up and play the game come from? Well, yeah, I don't know. I think I've always been really fascinated by that because I think there is something in the seeds of the game that give you an idea of fairness. It's a contest between batsman and bowler. And the contest is somehow, due to the dynamics of the game, the way it's scored, the length of the pitch and the equality between bat and ball, there's somehow a kind of fairness within the sport. the length of the pitch and the equality between bat and ball. Yeah.
这种“顶住并打好这场比赛”（play up and play the game）的想法是从哪里来的？嗯，是的，我不知道。我想我一直对这一点非常着迷，因为我认为这项运动的种子中确实蕴含着某种能给你公平理念的东西。这是击球手和投球手之间的较量。由于这项运动的动态、记分方式、球场的长度以及蝙蝠和球之间的平等，这种较量不知何故在运动中包含了一种公平，
There's somehow a kind of fairness within the sport, whereas if you do your best and you're good at it, you will succeed. But isn't there a counter-argument to that, that you mentioned WG Grace, and he's the Titanic figure in the history of cricket, really, but he's a notoriously bad sport. I mean, notorious for his gamesmanship. Yes, he's sort of, you know, there's the famous story about the guy, Charles
球场的长度以及蝙蝠和球之间的平等。是的。不知何故，运动中存在一种公平，如果你尽了最大努力并且擅长它，你就会成功。但难道没有与之相对的反驳观点吗？你提到了WG·格雷斯，他是板球史上的泰坦式人物，真的，但他是个出了名的糟糕的运动员。我的意思是，他以他的运动诡计（gamesmanship）而闻名。是的，他有点……你知道，有一个关于那个家伙查尔斯的著名故事……
Courtright, the fast bowler knocking two of WG's three stumps out of the ground and saying to him, going already doctor, there's still one stump left. I mean, WG was yes, you would say that. They've come to watch me
考特赖特，这个快球手，把WG的三根门柱打倒了两根，对他说：“这就走啦，医生？这儿还剩一根门柱呢。”我的意思是，WG会说：“是的，你们是来看我”
bat, not you umpire, all that sort of thing. But still, I think, how would I say it? You know, he's still governed by the framework of the game. He can't get away with everything. These things we're talking about, they might be close decisions. They might be, you know, I could have gone this way, I could have gone that way. So he exploited his fame and the laws in some way.
击球的，而不是来看你这个裁判的，”诸如此类。不过话说回来，我想，我该怎么说呢？你知道，他依然受制于比赛的框架。他不可能为所欲为。我们正在谈论的这些事情，可能是些胶着的判罚。它们可能是，你知道的，我本可以这么判，我本可以那么判。所以他在某种程度上利用了他的名气和比赛规则。
But at the heart of the game is this contest that you might say gives it its fairness and its kind of moral quality if there is one. See, if I was being sceptical, Tom, and you won't like this, I would say that as cricket is eclipsed eventually or is rivaled by football, particularly for their hearts and minds of kind of the industrial, urban working classes, then it becomes very important for cricket's sort of the Tom Holland figures to sanctify it as this pastoral, idealised repository. Tom Holland figures, I don't sanctify it at all. You do. You probably think it's sacral. I mean haven't mentioned christianity yet but it's
但在比赛的核心，是这种竞争，你可以说它赋予了比赛公平性以及某种道德品质，如果说它确实有的话。听着，如果我是个持怀疑态度的人，汤姆，你不会喜欢这个，我会说，随着板球最终被足球黯然失色，或者说受到足球的竞争——尤其是为了赢得那些工业、城市工人阶级的心灵和思想——那么，对于汤姆·霍兰德这样的人物来说，把板球奉为这样一个田园牧歌般的、理想化的精神宝库，就变得非常重要了。汤姆·霍兰德式的人物，我根本没有把它奉为神圣。你才这么做。你可能觉得它是神圣的。我的意思是，虽然还没提到基督教，但它
i'm sure the only moments away yeah well i mean no i think tom should mention christianity because i think that whole notion of cricket as a you know as an upstanding moral force does come from the sort of muscular christianity idea of health and vigor and fair play yeah i think it very much comes yeah but but but i mean cricket is an industrial sport as well as a a rural sport i mean that's the whole that's the whole key to it it's played it you know in leeds and in manchester and in birmingham just as it's played in sunset and not just not as well well but i mean i'm joking i always remember the the um kind of blinding realization of why was it that football and cricket were played you know in industrial cities whereas rugby wasn't and the answer is is that you can play cricket and football on cobbled hard stones
我敢肯定，离那也不远了。是的，我是说，不，我认为汤姆应该提到基督教，因为我认为板球作为一个堂堂正正的道德力量的整个概念，确实来自于那种充满健康、活力和公平竞争的“肌肉基督教”理念。是的，我认为它很大程度上就源于此。但是，但是，但是——我的意思是，板球既是一项乡村运动，也是一项工业运动，我的意思是，这才是全部的关键所在。它在利兹、曼彻斯特和伯明翰进行，就像它在萨默塞特进行一样，不，也不是——我是说我在开玩笑。我总是记得那种恍然大悟的时刻：为什么足球和板球是在工业城市进行的，而橄榄球却不是？答案是，你可以在铺满鹅卵石的坚硬石面上打板球和踢足球
yeah you know whereas rugby you can't because you've got to kind of throw yourself on the ground. It's going to be incredibly painful. So I think that, I mean, on this question of how cricket kind of bridges divides, another question from Luke, I don't know whether Luke, is cricket the ultimate metaphor for and symbol of British society cutting across the class and North-South divides the individual versus collective? And I think there is something to that. And it was definitely something that the British in the 19th century felt very, very kind of sentimental about.
而橄榄球则不行，因为你得把自己摔在地上。那会痛苦得难以置信。所以我觉得，关于板球如何弥合分歧这个问题，来自卢克的另一个问题——我不知道卢克是不是觉得板球是英国社会跨越阶级、南北分歧以及个人与集体对抗的终极隐喻和象征？我认为这里面确实有些道理。这绝对是19世纪的英国人感到非常、非常多愁善感的一点。
And Dominic, you were like this. They contrasted it with France. What did they play? Pétanque? On the day the Bastille was stormed, the Earl of Winchelsea, who's a key figure, he's kind of behind the drawing up of the laws of cricket,
多米尼克，你当时就持这种观点。他们把它与法国进行对比。他们玩什么？地滚球？在巴士底狱被攻陷的那天，温奇尔西伯爵（Lord Winchelsea，他是一个关键人物，可以说是板球规则制定背后的推手）
the sponsorship of the Marylebone Cricket Club, which is the MCC, ends up buying Lord's Cricket Ground, the most famous cricket ground in the world, in London. He was playing in the Hampshire-Kent match at Hambledon, which John mentioned, and he gets clean bowled by an agricultural labourer called William Bullen. This is on the day, the 14th of July or whatever? On the 14th of July, yeah.
玛丽lebone板球俱乐部（即MCC）的赞助人，最终买下了伦敦的Lord's板球场——世界上最著名的板球场。他当时正在汉普郡对阵肯特郡的比赛中效力，这场比赛约翰刚才也提到了，结果他被一个名叫威廉·布伦（William Bullen）的农场工人干净利落地三振出局（clean bowled）。这正是在那个日子，7月14日什么的？在7月14日，是的。
1789. Yeah. And G.M. Trevelyan, the great historian, writing about this, observed, if the French nobility had been capable of playing cricket with their peasants, their chateau would never have been burnt. Rule Britannia. come back we should look at um the ambivalent role that cricket has played in imperial british imperial domination of the world and the way in which the the colonized have used cricket to fight back so we'll see you after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q&A we pull back the
1789年。是的。伟大的历史学家G.M.特里维安（G.M. Trevelyan）在撰写这段历史时曾感慨道，如果法国贵族能够和他们的农民一起打板球，他们的城堡就绝不会被烧毁。统治吧，不列颠。等等，我们应该回过头来看看，板球在英国对世界的帝国统治中扮演的矛盾角色，以及被殖民者如何利用板球进行反抗。所以我们休息一会儿再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们联手主持《余音袅袅》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦点缀，而在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开
curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now some of you may have heard a very exciting development, which is that we have been having so much fun doing this show that we have launched our very own community, The Rest Is History Club. You're very excited about this, aren't you, Tom?
娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。现在，有些人可能已经听到一个非常令人兴奋的消息，那就是我们做这个节目玩得太开心了，以至于我们推出了我们自己的社区——《历史余音》俱乐部。你对此感到非常兴奋，对吧，汤姆？
I'm very excited about it. And what do you get? You get, well, I'll tell you one thing you get. You get every episode with no ads, including all the old episodes. So if you've, yeah, if you've already signed up to it, you won't be listening to this the days of the guardian saturday supplement of beer 52 of all our tremendous sponsors you'd be saying goodbye to all that which is a bit of a wrench i know however on top of that you would also get an extra episode every week it will go
我对此感到非常兴奋。你能得到什么？你会得到——好吧，我告诉你你能得到的一样东西。你可以收听没有广告的每一集节目，包括所有旧节目。所以，如果你已经注册了，你就不会在节目里听到《卫报》周六增刊、Beer 52以及我们所有强大赞助商的广告了。你要和这一切说再见了，我知道这有点让人不舍。不过，除此之外，你每周还会获得额外的一集节目。它将在
out on the uh on the tuesday and we'll be looking back at your comments your thoughts your feedback on the the previous week's episodes very much listener led very listener led yeah um and we'll be doing one live streamed episode every month on youtube and so we've got one coming up um next wednesday on the 15th of december that's going to be on the 60s yep that's very exciting membership of an exclusive chat room community which hilariously is called discord um i don't think we chose that name didn't we didn't we didn't but you can we'll be putting up reading lists uh chatting about the episodes laughing at tom's impersonations or expressing admiration for them um so lots lots of stuff um and it's very simple to set up uh even even we managed to do it now
周二发布，我们将回顾你们对前一周节目的评论、想法和反馈。这非常以听众为主导，极其以听众为主导。是的，呃，我们每个月还会在YouTube上进行一次直播节目。所以我们接下来将在12月15日（下周三）有一场直播，主题是关于60年代的。是的，这非常令人兴奋。加入一个独家聊天室社区，它滑稽地被称为Discord——我觉得这个名字不是我们选的，对吧？不是我们选的。但你可以——我们会发布书单、畅聊节目内容、嘲笑汤姆的模仿秀，或者表达对他的钦佩。所以内容非常丰富，而且设置起来非常简单——
now how much how unfortunately money has to change hands to join it's the way with clubs there isn't it i mean you always have to pay to join a club so how much do people have to pay to join this fantastic club a mere six british pounds per month yeah it's absolutely nothing what an ideal christmas gift that would be restishistorypod.com that's the what you need to know restishistorypod.com however just to reiterate if you don't want to be bothered with any of that you can carry on listening and you'll get the two episodes as per normal completely for free every week yeah but you should join the club anyway i mean you really should and now back to the cricket
现在，为了加入这个俱乐部，不幸的是必须有金钱交易。俱乐部嘛，总是这样，对吧？加入俱乐部总是需要付费的。那么人们需要花多少钱才能加入这个 fantastique（精彩的）俱乐部呢？每月仅需6英镑！是的，这完全不算什么。多么理想的圣诞礼物啊！restishistorypod.com，这就是你需要了解的网址：restishistorypod.com。不过，重申一下，如果你不想为这些事情烦恼，你可以继续听节目，每周照常可以完全免费收听两集。是的，但你无论如何都应该加入这个俱乐部——我是说，你真的应该加入。现在，让我们回到板球上来。
welcome back to the rest is history uh we are talking about the history of cricket. So we've done rakish origins. We have talked a little bit about the Victorians. And now we're going to look abroad. Now, here is an amazing fact. John, is this true? I read this online. I'm not ashamed to admit I'm reading it on Wikipedia. It says the first ever international cricket match took place between the United States and Canada in 1844.
欢迎回到《历史余音》，我们正在讨论板球的历史。所以我们已经聊过了它放荡不羁的起源。我们也聊了一点维多利亚时代的人。现在我们要放眼海外。现在，这里有一个惊人的事实。约翰，这是真的吗？我在网上看到的。我不耻承认我是从维基百科上看到的。上面说，有史以来第一场国际板球比赛是1844年在美国和加拿大之间进行的。
Can that possibly be true? It is more than true. It's an established fact of the game. Yes, I mean, it's very odd that cricket did have this very brief hold and grip in the United States and Canada, mostly on the eastern seaboard, as you'd expect and as we'll come to discuss, because the Brits got over there and started playing it. And somehow, and I think no one's really worked out how and why, it loses that grip and in its place comes...
这怎么可能是真的？这千真万确。这是这项运动公认的事实。是的，我的意思是，非常奇怪的是，板球确实在美国和加拿大有过非常短暂的流行和影响力，主要在东海岸，正如你所预料的那样，正如我们接下来要讨论的那样，因为英国人到达那里并开始玩这项运动。不知何故——我想没有人真正弄清楚是如何以及为什么——它失去了这种影响力，取而代之的是……
Well, John, you know, when the Pilgrim Fathers go and they have their first Christmas, and there are loads of people who've gone with them who aren't pilgrims, and they all go out to have a prayer on Christmas Day. And they come back and they find that they're playing cricket. These other people are playing cricket. So they confiscate their bat and ball, which I think is where America went wrong. That could be the exact moment.
嗯，约翰，你知道的，当清教徒先父们（Pilgrim Fathers）去过他们的第一个圣诞节时，同行的人中有很多并不是清教徒，他们在圣诞节那天出去做祷告。等他们回来时，发现那些人在打板球。那些人在打板球。于是他们没收了人家的球拍和球，我认为这就是美国走错路的地方。这可能就是那个关键时刻。
I've heard it said that it's partly to do with Union soldiers in the American Civil War found it easier to play baseball than than cricket uh just to play an impromptu game is simpler and also that it's when after the american civil war that america has a much stronger sense of itself as an alternative to europe rather than a sort of a descendant of it so they need their own game as part of a kind of american nationalism and stuff i don't yeah that sounds a bit kind of retrofitted but uh okay but i mean it could be couldn't it it could be it really could be i mean i think i think the interesting thing is that and a lot of places that don't have cricket there is a game like cricket that has a sense of time and um a sort of an internal relation a game you can have an internal ongoing long relationship with like baseball like baseball
我曾听人说过，这部分与美国内战中的联邦士兵有关，他们发现打棒球比打板球更容易，随时来一场即兴比赛更简单；还有一个原因是，在美国内战之后，美国对自身的认同感大大增强，更倾向于把自己视为欧洲的替代品，而不是欧洲的某种后代，所以他们需要自己的运动来作为美国民族主义等情绪的一部分。我不——是的，这听起来有点像事后诸葛亮，不过……好吧，但它确实有可能是真的，真的有可能。我的意思是，我认为有趣的是，在许多没有板球的地方，都有一种类似于板球的运动，它有一种时间感，以及一种内在的关系——一种你可以与之建立长期的、进行中的内在关系的运动，就像棒球一样，就像棒球一样。
and baseball you could hold up as but but i think you know a lot of places do have equivalents but it's interesting so um america obviously rejects britain that's the whole point of it uh and and so in a sense as cricket becomes more and more identified with britain so it becomes more and more important i guess to america to have a sport that is not cricket the the contrast with that is australia which is likewise a settler society but where cricket really does put down massive routes very quickly um we i mean to the degree that so we have a question here from um and and i think that this touches on all kinds of fascinating issues from dan norcross who is of course a commentator on test match special um would love you to dwell a
你可以把棒球举例为……但我想，你知道，很多地方确实有对应的运动，但这很有趣，所以——美国显然拒绝了英国，这才是关键所在。因此，从某种意义上说，随着板球越来越与英国划等号，对于美国来说，拥有一个不是板球的运动也就变得越来越重要了。与此形成鲜明对比的是澳大利亚，它同样是一个殖民地社会，但板球在那里迅速扎下了极其深厚的根基。我们——我的意思是，程度之深，以至于我们这里有一个来自……的问题，我认为这触及了各种迷人的议题，来自丹·诺克罗斯（Dan Norcross），他当然是“测试赛特别专栏”（Test Match Special）的评论员。他希望我们多讲讲
little on the australian aboriginals tour of england in 1868 the team held its own and was largely well received across the country apart from york but returned to australia penniless and barely any of them played cricket seriously again so So in 1868, a team of indigenous Australians are coming over and playing cricket. I mean, that seems amazing. It does. I mean, I think, again, you know, we mentioned novelty earlier. And I think that that's a factor here. You know, this this idea that cricket loves that kind of thing. It's something to come and stare at. It's something that will fill up a day. I think the really, really interesting thing, and you are probably
1868年澳大利亚原住民板球代表团对英国的巡回赛。这支队伍表现不俗，在全国各地基本上受到了热烈欢迎（除了约克郡），但回到澳大利亚时却身无分文，而且他们当中几乎没有人再认真打过板球了。所以，在1868年，一支澳大利亚本土土著球队来到英国并进行板球比赛。我的意思是，这听起来太惊人了。确实如此。我的意思是，我认为，同样地（我们之前提到过“猎奇”），我认为这也是其中的一个因素。你知道，这种想法是板球运动很喜欢那种调调。这是一个可以去围观的奇观。这是能填满一天时间的事情。我认为非常、非常有趣的一点是——你可能比我更有资格谈论这次巡回赛——那就是达尔文的《物种起源》刚刚出版。当时它已经出版了——我不知道，大约10年左右，或者可能比那还要短一点——当这支球队抵达时，维多利亚时代的人们带着一种现在看来极其可怕的、带着有色眼镜的眼光看着他们（用我们现在看来很可怕的描述在报纸上描绘他们的外貌、头发、胡须等等）。所以，是的，你可以想象自己是那支球队的一员，那会是怎样的感受。好吧，我的意思是，我在这里读到的关于这件事的资料令人难以置信。所以在比赛结束时，他们会进行回旋镖和投掷标枪的表演。有一个人，他们中的一个叫迪克·迪克（Dicker Dick）的人，会拿着一个狭窄的盾牌，人们花钱向他投掷板球。是的。
far better qualified to talk about this than I am, about this tour is that the origin of the species, Darwin, had just come out. It'd been out for, i don't know 10 years or something like that maybe less than that uh when this team arrived and there's this kind of horrible now again talking retrospectively sort of goggle-eyed looking at them by the victor you know and descript you know horrible we would think of now horrible descriptions in the paper of how they looked, their hair, their beards, you know. So, yeah, you imagine being one of that team and how that must have been. Well, I mean, the stuff I'm reading here about it, extraordinary. So at the end of the games, they would put on an exhibition of boomerang and spear throwing. And a man called, one of them who was called Dicker Dick, would hold a narrow shield and people would pay to throw cricket balls at him. Yeah.
我的意思是，很难想象这会被重新引入这项运动中。但同样，这——是的，这就像是有钱人在消磨时间，不是吗？我们去罗兹（Lourdes）球场吧。看看，是的，比赛结束后，我们看看谁能把球最狠地砸向他。但有趣的是——我的意思是，这也令人着迷的是，
I mean, that would be, it's hard to see that being reintroduced into the game. But again, this is, yeah, it's like, it's these rich guys trying to fill up their time, isn't it? Let's go down to Lourdes. Let's see, yeah, after the game, we'll see if you can chuck the ball hardest at him. But what's, I mean, also what's fascinating about that, though,
那是大概在澳大利亚国家队来英国比赛之前很久的事情了。是的，好吧，这……而我们正是在刚刚在澳大利亚拉开帷幕的“灰烬杯”（The Ashes）的背景下讨论这件事。但到底是什么让……所以给我们讲讲“灰烬杯”是怎么诞生的，约翰，以及为什么英格兰和澳大利亚会产生这种史诗般的、泰坦般的……我觉得纯粹
is that it's presumably well before Australian national teams are coming over and playing England. Yeah, well, it's... And we're doing this against the backdrop of the Ashes that have just started in Australia. But what is it about... So tell us how the As come into being john and and why it is that england australia come to have this kind of epic quality this titanic i think purely
简而言之，就是因为你能去那里。你知道，突然之间，通过船只，有了一种去某个地方的方法。这就是为什么板球的全部存在都遵循这种维多利亚时代的世俗时间尺度。比赛要持续好几天，因为当时人们无所事事，他们想去看一场能持续一段时间的比赛。巡回赛、板球巡回赛，以及国际板球的结构方式是，一个国家去和另一个国家进行一系列比赛，通常会在那个国家待上好几个月。我的意思是，有些巡回赛进展缓慢，但早期的巡回赛会持续六个月。所以板球是一项夏季运动。你必须去一个天气炎热的地方才能打它。
and simply it's because you could get there you know all of a sudden there was a you know by by boat there was a method of going somewhere and this is why you know the whole of cricket exists on these sort of victorian time scales you, it goes on for several days because people had nothing to do and they wanted to go and watch something that lasted for a while. Tours, cricket tours, and the way international cricket is structured is that one country goes off to play a series of matches against another country and they will stay in that country for several months while they do it, usually. I mean, some tours are slow, but the early tours would last for six months. So cricket's a summer game. You have to go somewhere where it's hot to play it.
所以在英国的冬天，你去哪里？基本上你必须去南半球。所以他们扬帆起航前往澳大利亚。国际比赛的概念再次出现。这是一件……你知道的，WG在比赛中打出了英格兰历史上的第一个测试赛百分。它的到来再次比他的巅峰期稍微晚了一点。我以为你说这使得一场测试赛成为测试赛。好吧，我的意思是，再次强调，是什么让一场测试赛成为测试赛？
So in the English winter, where do you go? You have to go to the Southern Hemisphere, essentially. So they set sail to Australia. The notion of internationals comes along again. It's something, you know, WG scores England's first Test Match 100. It arrives again a little too late for his prime. I thought you said it makes a Test Match a Test Match. Well, I mean, again, what makes a Test Match a Test Match?
它的比赛时间比……所以对于懂行的人来说，测试赛就是国际比赛。测试赛就是国际比赛，而且它们会持续很久。对于那些不来自板球运动国家的普通人来说，它们会持续五天。比赛可能会以平局告终。不仅持续五天，一个系列赛通常还会有五场这样的比赛。
It's played slightly longer than... So for people who know, Test Matches are international matches. Test Matches are international matches and they last. And people who don't really come from non-cricket playing countries, they last for five days. It can end in a draw. And not only do they last for five days, there are usually five of them in a series.
是的，而且它们会消磨精力。我的意思是，这会让海外听众感到无比震惊和喜爱。所以，是的，这个……再次出现，我猜（正如人们常说的那样），它被称为测试赛（Test match），因为它是一次考验，你知道的，它是对时间和技巧以及耐力的终极考验，而且你身处异国他乡……很难想象，如果你打过测试赛，
Yeah, and they break fatigue. I mean, that will be the thing that will really astound and love overseas listeners. So, yes, where does this, you know, this, again, I mean, I guess, you know, it's always famously said it's called test cricket because it is a test, you know, it's the ultimate test of time and skill and endurance and, you know, you're in a foreign... It's really difficult to, I mean, if you've played test cricket,
要让一个测试赛板球手出局真的是难上加难，多米尼克。闭嘴吧。更不用说两个了，更不用说两个了。但我并不认为你把他们罚下场时他们正处于巅峰期，对吧？他们是测试赛板球手，多米尼克。我淘汰了两个测试赛板球手。我只是顺便提一下。约翰，当你和你的队伍比赛时，他经常提这事吗？
really very difficult to get a test cricketer out, Dominic. Oh, shut up. Let alone two, let alone two. But I don't think they were in their prime when you got them out, were they? They were test cricketers, Dominic. I got two test cricketers. I'm just putting that in. John, does he mention this a lot when you're playing in your team?
是的，我提过。我们别聊这个了。国际板球的概念，我们应该回到那个话题吗？好的。英格兰对阵澳大利亚成了真正的第一场较量。他们是前两支参加测试赛的国家。他们打了第一场测试赛。
I do, yes. Let's not talk about it. The notion of international cricket, should we go back to that? Yes. England versus Australia becomes the first real contest. They're the first two test match playing nations. They can test the first test match. terribly free and it's so destructive to the english vision of themselves a couple of likely lads take a uh a piss-taking advert in in the in the times newspaper saying that um the yeah this this defeat is so terrible that they've burned the uh they've burned the remains of english cricket um and put them in in this little urn. And that becomes known as the ashes.
非常随意，而且对英国人自我形象的打击极大：两个爱开玩笑的家伙在《泰晤士报》上刊登了一则恶作剧广告，上面写着……是的，这次失败太惨了，他们已经把英格兰板球的残余骨灰烧掉了，并把它们装进了一个小骨灰瓮里。这就是后来闻名遐迩的“灰烬杯”（The Ashes）。
What is in the urn? I mean, I've seen it. What's in it? Supposedly. Supposedly. I mean, who knows? It's two bales, isn't it? It's the bales from the game. So in cricket, you have the stumps, which are what the bowlers aim at.
那骨灰瓮里装的是什么？我的意思是，我见过的。里面装的是什么？据说。据说。谁知道呢？那是两个球门盖（bale），对吧？那是比赛中的球门盖。所以在板球中，你有三根“门柱”（stump），也就是投球手瞄准的目标。
And there are three of those. And across the top of the stumps are a couple of smaller bits of wood, which are called the bales. And they have to be knocked off in order for a dismissal to occur and this is 1882 isn't it so this is the this is the first the first ashes test match yeah and then uh the contest is enjoined this it catches the imagination obviously and i think australia winning was a big part of that i think i think it was important australia won that because immediately well English said, well, we can't have that. We've got to win it back. So the contest, had England won the first 30 Ashes test matches incredibly easily, I Australia, you could argue that the Ashes kind of channel both an opportunity for Australians to demonstrate that they've emancipated themselves from the mother country, from the kind of,
有三根这样的柱子，而在门柱的顶端横放着两个较小的木条，被称为“球门盖”（bale）。必须将它们击落才能让击球手出局。这是1882年，对吧？所以这是第一场——第一场灰烬杯测试赛，是的。然后，这场竞赛就拉开帷幕了。这显然激发了人们的想象力，我认为澳大利亚的获胜是其中很大的一部分。我认为澳大利亚赢得那场比赛很重要，因为英格兰人立刻说：“好吧，我们不能这样。我们必须把它赢回来。”因此这场较量——如果英格兰极其轻松地赢得了前30场灰烬杯测试赛的话，也就是说，澳大利亚队，你可以说灰烬杯既为澳大利亚人提供了一个机会，让他们证明自己已经从宗主国那里解放出来，摆脱了澳大利亚建立时所带有的那种殖民主义色彩，
you know, the colonialism with which Australia had been founded. But at the same time, because cricket is so distinctively English, it enables them to maintain ties as well. I mean, would you say that that's part of the role that cricket has played in Anglo-Australian relations? Yeah, I think so. I think it's that notion of, you know, in its simplest form, beating your own game, you know. And that's played out not just in England versus Australia.
你知道的。但与此同时，由于板球是如此具有英格兰特色，它也使他们能够保持联系。我的意思是，你会不会说这也是板球在英安（英澳）关系中发挥的作用的一部分？是的，我想是的。我认为这就是那种理念，用最简单的话来说，就是在他们自己的运动中击败他们。你知道的。这不仅体现在英格兰对阵澳大利亚的比赛中。
Really, the cricket, the history of international cricket is the history of empire. Well, hold on, Dominic. John, before we come, just specifically on Australia. So the most famous, indeed, most notorious Ashes series becomes known as the Bodyline series. Yes. And that's in the 1930s. It's a tremendous name, isn't it? See, I think whoever came up with that, that made it historic as well, Bodyline. Okay, so just tell us about the Bodyline series and why that was,
实际上，板球运动——国际板球的历史就是帝国的历史。等等，多米尼克。约翰，在我们继续之前，先谈谈澳大利亚。所以最著名、甚至可以说是最声名狼藉的灰烬杯系列赛被称为“身体线系列赛”（Bodyline series）。是的。那是在20世纪30年代。这是一个了不起的名字，对吧？你看，我觉得无论是谁想出这个名字的，这也让它载入了史册，“身体线”。好吧，那么给我们讲讲身体线系列赛，以及为什么会这样，
I mean, it was much more than a sporting story. It was a huge crisis in Anglo-Australian relations and, in fact, in the entire fabric of the british empire yeah well well after after you know grace grace became the this this this defining cricketer and after grace there were lots of really good cricketers but uh in the 1920s and 30s comes along a player called donald bradman who probably even to this day remains sport's greatest outlier. By the statistics, Bradman is... Of every sport. Of every sport.
我的意思是，这远不止是一个体育故事。这是英澳关系中的一场巨大危机，事实上，也是整个大英帝国体制的一场危机。是的，好吧——在……你知道，格雷斯（Grace）成为了这位具有决定性意义的板球手，而在格雷斯之后，还有很多非常优秀的板球手，但在20世纪20年代和30年代，出现了一位名叫唐纳德·布拉德曼（Donald Bradman）的球员，他可能直到今天仍然是体育界最伟大的异类。从统计数据来看，布拉德曼是……在所有运动中。在所有运动中。
By the statistics, Bradman is between 30% and 40% better than anyone else who's ever played cricket. Better than WG Grace? Yes, by the statistics. So if we use statistics as a measure, there isn't another sport in which one person has been that far ahead of the field for as long as Bradman was ahead of the field and has remained ahead of the field. So Bradman comes along, immediately begins scoring runs at a rate that
从数据来看，布拉德曼比任何其他打过板球的人都要出色30%到40%。比WG·格雷斯还要好？是的，从数据上来看。所以如果我们把统计数据作为衡量标准，没有任何其他运动能让一个人在如此长的时间里把所有人远远抛在身后，就像布拉德曼那样遥遥领先，并一直保持领先地位。所以布拉德曼出现了，并且立即开始以一种前所未见的速度得分。
no one has ever seen before. And England's captain, Douglas Jardine at times, as people know, I think he was actually Scottish, but he comes to represent England and empire and all of those things because he's the sort of guy you could imagine plays the national anthem before he goes to bed. Nothing wrong with that. As we all do, obviously. So he goes out to Australia with the aim of winning back the ashes from Bradman's Australia. And he comes up with a plan to combat Bradman.
而英格兰的队长道格拉斯·贾丁（Douglas Jardine）有时——正如大家所知，我认为他其实是个苏格兰人——但他开始代表英格兰和帝国以及所有这些事物，因为他是那种你会觉得他在上床睡觉前都会播放国歌的人。这没有什么不对的。正如我们大家显而易见都会做的那样。所以他前往澳大利亚，目标是从布拉德曼的澳大利亚手中夺回灰烬杯。他想出了一个对付布拉德曼的计划。
And that plan is essentially for his bowlers to bowl it as fast as they can at Bradman's head and body. And the cricket ball is, you know, again, if you don't know anything about cricket, cricket ball is made of leather it has a cork interior it's rock it's very hard it's especially when it's new it's rock hard and cricket's a dangerous game people are you know the history of cricket is littered with people who've died playing it partly because the ball was very hard and is propelled towards you at 90 miles an hour from 22 yards away you don't have a lot of time to get out of the way and this this tactic of of um of jardines slightly more sophisticated than i've described but essentially it was built around you know uh physical danger and fear and and that goes back to this victorian moral sense of game. Is that a legitimate tactic?
而这个计划本质上就是让他的投球手以最快的速度朝布拉德曼的头部和身体投球。而板球是——你知道的，如果你对板球一无所知的话，板球是由皮革制成的，里面有软木内核，它是坚硬的、非常坚硬的，特别是当它是新球的时候，硬得像石头一样。板球是一项危险的运动，板球的历史上充穿着因打板球而丧命的人，部分原因就是球非常硬，而且以每小时90英里的速度从22码外向你飞来，你没有多少时间躲开。而贾丁的这种战术——虽然比我描述的要稍微复杂一点点，但本质上它是围绕着肉体上的危险和恐惧建立起来的——这可以追溯到维多利亚时代的博弈道德感。这是一种合法的战术吗？
Is it cricket? So they call it leg theory, don't they? Jardine didn't like it being called, you know, the term body line that's come to represent it. That certainly wasn't his term. His term was leg theory. Again, without giving you a description of how cricket's played, I can't tell you why that makes sense.
这算板球吗？所以他们称之为“腿侧战术”（leg theory），对吧？贾丁不喜欢别人叫它——你知道的，后来代表它的那个词叫“身体线”（body line）。那绝对不是他的术语。他的术语是“腿侧战术”。同样，如果不向你描述板球是怎么玩的，我就无法告诉你为什么这说得通。
But it does make sense as a description of what it is. But essentially it causes an international incident. At government level, body line becomes a problem because by now you've got newsreel footage and people can see this happening that weren't at the grounds. And they see... Yeah, kind of ball thudding into the batsman and the batsman falling down.
但作为对它的一种描述，它确实说得通。不过本质上它引发了一场国际事件。在政府层面，“身体线”成了一个问题，因为此时你已经有了新闻片（newsreel footage），不在现场的人也能看到正在发生的事情。他们看到……是的，球沉闷地砸在击球手身上，击球手倒在地上。
The batsman falling to the ground. And Bradman, if we give you a kind of really simple overview of what he was doing, Bradman, every time he went into bat, would score around 100 runs, which is a lot of runs in cricket. Well, Jardine's tactic essentially halves that. So Bradman scores around 50 runs per inning. Just excellent captaincy, in my mind. So really, he just brings Bradman back to everyone's level.
击球手倒在地上。而布拉德曼——如果我们给你一个非常简单的概述，他当时在做什么——布拉德曼每次上场击球，都能拿到大约100分，这在板球里是相当多的分数。而贾丁的战术基本上将这个数字减半了。所以布拉德曼每局只能得大约50分。这在我看来简直是卓越的队长艺术。所以实际上，他只是把布拉德曼拉回了所有人的水平。
That's what his tactic did. Why is it such an international incident? I mean, is this genuinely something that governments are kind of concerned about? Yeah, famously questions were asked in Parliament because, you know, at this point, cricket is representing something beyond cricket. But it's also because it's in the 30s. Britain is feeling nervous about the future of the empire. It's under geopolitical threat. And suddenly the Australians are saying there are two sides out there and only one is playing cricket yeah um that was not a very good australian accent by your standards tom no it wasn't only two sides
这就是他的战术所达到的效果。为什么这会成为如此轰动的国际事件？我的意思是，这真的是那种让政府感到担忧的事情吗？是的，正如人们所熟知的，议会里曾有人提出质询，因为在这个时候，板球代表了板球运动本身之外的意义。但这也是因为当时正处于30年代。英国对帝国的未来感到焦虑。它面临着地缘政治的威胁。突然之间，澳大利亚人说：“场上有两支队伍，但只有一支在打板球。”——你刚才那个澳大利亚口音模仿得不太好，汤姆。不，确实不太好。“场上有两支队伍，但只有一支在打板球”——好多了，对，是的。而且
out there and only one's playing cricket much better much yeah and um australia has a sense of national identity post world war one doesn't it exactly yeah you know it's playing into all that it's playing yeah and uh i mean doug stardew even though he's scottish embodies for australians the absolute archetype of a kind of sinister english milord kind of yeah he's played but i didn't there's a brilliant uh well it wasn't brilliant but it was hugely enjoyable uh drama about it in which he was played by um the guy who plays elrond in lord of the rings. Hugo Weaving. Yes, Hugo Weaving. Yeah, he's great.
澳大利亚在第一次世界大战后有着强烈的民族认同感，对吧？完全正确，是的。你知道，这一切都在发挥作用，是的。而且——我的意思是，道格拉斯·贾丁尽管是个苏格兰人，但在澳大利亚人眼中，他完美地化身成了某种傲慢阴险的英国老爷的绝对原型。你知道的，他虽然扮演了……但有一个精彩的——好吧，也不能算精彩，但这是一部极具观赏性的相关电视剧，里面扮演他的是那个在《指环王》里扮演埃尔隆德（Elrond）的演员。雨果·维文（Hugo Weaving）。是的，雨果·维文。是的，他演得很棒。
And it seems to Australians absolutely indicative of the British class system, that he's very posh. And the bowler that he's getting to do this incredibly violent bowling is Harold Larwood. He's been rustled up from a Nottinghamshire coal mine. He's D.H. Lawrence. He's D.H. Lawrence. And of course, all the blame ends up being dumped on Harold Larwood,
在澳大利亚人看来，这绝对是英国阶级制度的象征，他非常高贵势利。而他找来执行这种极其暴力的投球战术的投球手是哈罗德·拉伍德（Harold Larwood）。他是从诺丁汉郡的煤矿里被发掘出来的。他简直就是D.H.劳伦斯。他就是D.H.劳伦斯。当然，所有的指责最终都倾泻在了哈罗德·拉伍德身上，
not on Jardine. Not on Jardine, yeah. Well, I mean, Jardine was unrepentant about it and had that view that it was a legitimate tactic and he just exploited the laws of the game, which had been done since time immemorial. So Australia, it's two predominantly white countries playing one another.
而不是贾丁。没有责怪贾丁，是的。好吧，我的意思是，贾丁对此毫无悔意，并坚持认为这是一种合法的战术，他只是利用了自古以来就有的比赛规则。所以对澳大利亚来说，这是两个主要由白人组成的国家在互相竞技。
In the West Indies, in India, it's different because there are additional dynamics there, which are particularly focused in the West Indies around issues of slavery and race. Well, mean the west indies yeah we well sorry we should quickly go back to empire and say if you if you look on the map of of test playing nations international cricket nations although it's a bit bigger now you you might as well have drawn the british empire on the map because it's in India and it's in Australia and it's in the West Indies.
而在西印度群岛、在印度，情况则有所不同，因为那里有额外的动力，这些动力在西印度群岛尤为集中在奴隶制和种族问题上。好吧，我的意思是西印度群岛，是的，我们——抱歉，我们应该迅速回到帝国的话题上来，如果你看一下测试赛国家、国际板球国家的地图，尽管现在地图大了一些，但你完全可以把大英帝国直接画在地图上，因为它存在于印度、澳大利亚和西印度群岛。
But the extraordinary thing about the West Indies is that it doesn't exist. It exists only as a cricket team. It's a collection of autonomous islands. And I think it exists in two forms. It exists as a university. There's a university of West Indies and there's a West Indies cricket team.
但西印度群岛最奇妙的地方在于，它并不存在。它只作为一个板球团队存在。它是一群自治岛屿的集合。我认为它以两种形式存在：它存在于一所大学——有西印度群岛大学（University of West Indies）——还有一个西印度群岛板球队。
But those are the only two places in which it does exist. And yet it comes to represent something enormous to that region, to those people and to the diaspora as it spreads out. And as, you know, the Windrush generation come to England and make lives here, it assumes huge significance in their lives and not just as a game of cricket. And when did the West Indies start playing test cricket? Well, they come into it when most of these others start coming along. England and Australia play away together for 20 or 30 years and then you get the West Indies coming along.
但这是它仅有的两个存在的地方。然而，它对那个地区、对那些人民以及随着它向外扩散的海外移民群体来说，代表着极其巨大的意义。而且，随着温德拉什世代（Windrush generation）来到英国并在这里生活，它在他们的生活中占据了极其重要的地位，而不仅仅是一场板球比赛。那么西印度群岛是什么时候开始打测试赛的呢？好吧，他们是在大多数其他国家加入的时候加入进来的。英格兰和澳大利亚一起客场打了20或30年的比赛，然后西印度群岛才加入进来。
So you're talking about the early part of the last century and then by the 1950s you've also got uh pakistan and you've got india and then sri lanka join even later than that and so over the course of the century all of these places come and join and start playing cricket do you think i mean do you think that the it's it's quite a kind of complicated dynamic, isn't it? Because it's not just, so for the British, the British associate cricket with their own civilization, it's a marker of their,
所以你谈论的是上个世纪的早期，然后到了20世纪50年代，你还有了巴基斯坦和印度，然后斯里兰卡加入的时间甚至更晚，所以在整个世纪的进程中，所有这些地方都加入进来并开始打板球。你觉得——我的意思是，你觉得这是一种相当复杂的动态，不是吗？因为不仅仅是——所以对英国人来说，英国人把板球与他们自己的文明联系在一起，这是他们……的标志。
you know, their, their values, their, their kind of everything that they see the British empire at its best as embodied teamwork, sportsmanship, those things.
你知道的，他们的价值观，他们的一切——他们认为大英帝国在其巅峰时所体现的团队精神、体育精神，诸如此类。
And so therefore for say, you know, the therefore, for, say, the planters in the Caribbean or for Maharajas in India, it's a way of basically kind of sucking up to the British. It's a way of kind of aligning themselves with the values of the colonial power. But then that enables the roots to be put down, but then it gets taken up by people, by the kind of the masses, and becomes a way of kind of fighting back against British claims to supremacy. And the West Indies is the
因此，对于加勒比海地区的种植园主或印度的王公贵族来说，这基本上是巴结英国人的一种方式。这是一种让自己与殖民统治者的价值观保持一致的方式。但这使得板球能够扎下根基，随后它被大众所接受，并成为回击英国人至高无上主张的一种方式。而西印度群岛就是其中最引人注目的例证。
most kind of dramatic illustration of that. Because, you know, the roots of cricket in the Caribbean do go back to a time where you have, you know, where the aristocrats and it's the bowlers who are the kind of the peasantry. In the Caribbean, it's even more kind of dramatic. And that, you know, slaves are being employed basically to bowl at the masters, which is why increasingly they bowl faster and faster and faster to try and make the masters hot. And so that's kind of the tradition of fast bowling in the West Indies that you still get. But of course, to stand at the wicket and to smack around white bowlers for a black batsman, again, I mean, it's an incredible. It's amazingly symbolic, isn't it? You know, that's the, I mean, and also for.
因为，你知道的，板球在加勒比海地区的根基确实可以追溯到这样一个时代：贵族们打球，而投球手则是农民。在加勒比海地区，这种戏剧性甚至更强。而且，你知道的，奴隶基本上被雇来向主人投球，这就是为什么他们投得越来越快、越来越快，试图把主人弄得狼狈不堪。所以这也就是西印度群岛那种一直延续至今的快球风格的传统。当然，对于一个黑人击球手来说，站在球门前，把白人投球手的球狠狠地击飞，这再次意味着……这是一件不可思议的事情。这具有惊人的象征意义，不是吗？你知道，这就是——我的意思是，而且对于……
Can I quote you a line from the Whalers? Yeah. Slave driver, the table is turned, catch a fire. Yeah. But isn't there that famous moment in the 1970s when the England captain, what is his name? Tony Gregg. Tony Gregg.
我能引用威勒乐队（The Wailers）的一句歌词吗？“奴隶主，风水轮流转，烈火燎原。”是的。但是，难道在20世纪70年代没有那个著名的时刻吗？当时英格兰队长——他叫什么名字？托尼·格雷格（Tony Gregg）。托尼·格雷格。
He says he wants to make the West Indies grovel. And there's this huge furore, isn't there? Because that scene is basically... He's a South African. Although he's captain of England, he's South African. A rhetorical kind of reassertion of the old master-slave dynamic. I mean, that's maybe a bit harsh on Tony Greig, but that's exactly how it's interpreted.
他说他想让西印度群岛人俯首帖耳（grovel）。然后引发了一场巨大的风波，对吧？因为这一幕基本上是……他是个南非人。尽管他是英格兰队的队长，但他是个南非人。这是一种对旧的主奴关系的修辞式重申。我的意思是，这可能对托尼·格雷格有点苛刻，但这正是人们对它的解读。
Well, look, that's one of the hugely significant times in West Indies cricket. The first is probably, you should say, in 1950, was when they first beat England in a test match. And the first time that all of the other test playing nations beat England in a test match, it takes on an extraordinary significance for them. That plays out through the history of the game.
好吧，看，那是西印度群岛板球运动中具有重大意义的时刻之一。第一次可能可以说是1950年，当时他们第一次在测试赛中击败了英格兰。其他所有测试赛国家第一次在测试赛中击败英格兰时，对他们来说都具有非凡的意义。这一点贯穿了这项运动的历史。
But then, yeah, come the 1970s, and that tour that you're talking about happened in 1976, the summer of 1976 in england which is you know as you all know dominic was just a time you know it was the time of punk rock it was the time it was garbage in the streets and you know all of this stuff's going on james callahan he is yeah glad we got him in yeah a backdrop to all jesus and james callahan and and here come this cricket team and this was the first time i ever went to a test match as a little kid here comes here come this west indies cricket team was the first time I ever went to a test match as a little kid. Here comes this West Indies cricket team.
但随后，是的，到了20世纪70年代，你所说的那个巡回赛发生在1976年，1976年的那个夏天在英国——你知道的，正如你们大家所知道的，多米尼克，那正是一个时代，你知道的，那是朋克摇滚的时代，那是垃圾遍地的时代，你知道的，所有这些事情都在发生，詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callahan），他当时是……是的，很高兴我们把他也扯进来了，是的，作为这一切的背景，哦，天哪，詹姆斯·卡拉汉，然后这支板球队来了。正是在这个时候，我作为一个小男孩，第一次去看了测试赛。这支西印度群岛板球队来了，正是在这个时候，我作为一个小男孩，第一次去看了测试赛。这支西印度群岛板球队来了。
And they are like gods. I mean, they are like gods among men. They bowl faster. They hit the ball further. They're incredibly athletic in the field. They're playing a new kind of cricket that no one's seen before. I mean, it begins a revolution in the game. And they're sort of summed up by the man
他们就像神一样。我的意思是，他们就像凡人中的神。他们投球更快。他们击球更远。他们在场上极其矫健。他们正在打一种前所未见的崭新板球。我的意思是，这开启了一场比赛的革命。他们某种程度上被这个人所概括，
who becomes their leading batsman, Viv Richards, who's this incredibly, his nickname was Smoking Joe because he looked a bit like Joe Frazier and he had that kind of boxer's physique, incredible Roman nose, and he carried himself with such. He's my absolute hero.
他成为了他们的主力击球手，维夫·理查兹（Viv Richards）。他是一个极其……他的绰号叫“吸烟的乔”（Smoking Joe），因为他看起来有点像乔·弗雷泽（Joe Frazier），他有着那种拳击手的体格，有着令人难以置信的罗马鼻，而且他举止间流露出……他绝对是我的英雄。
Yeah, and mine. And I think, you know, the amazing thing that that team did, certainly for me and for a lot of people, is it just made it impossible to think of West Indies and West Indies as anything other than superior beings. Yeah.
是的，也是我的。而且我认为，那支球队所做到的了不起的事情——对我和许多人来说绝对如此——就是它让人根本无法把西印度群岛和西印度群岛人视为超越凡人之上的存在以外的任何形象。是的。
Because they were just, they were, you know, the England team at that time were led by Tony Gregg who was a South African but was a six foot seven sort of beanpole guy who ran in a strange way and batted in a strange way
因为他们就是——你知道的，当时的英格兰队由托尼·格雷格率领，他是个南非人，但却是一个身高六尺七寸的高瘦竹竿男，跑步的姿势很奇怪，击球的姿势也很奇怪，
they had David Steele in the team who was grey haired in his thirties wore glasses kind of John Major didn't he he was known as the bank clerk who went to war they had they had Derek Underwood as a spin bowler who he sort of looked like an Oxford Don you know he's
他们的队伍里还有大卫·斯蒂尔（David Steele），他30多岁就满头白发，戴着眼镜，有点像约翰·梅杰（John Major），不是吗？他被称为“上战场职员”（the bank clerk who went to war）。他们还有德里克·安德伍德（Derek Underwood）作为旋转投球手，他看起来有点像牛津大学的导师（Don），你知道的，他
prematurely bowled his feet splayed out when he ran and you're comparing them to these these guys who are like they must have looked at the England teams thought what what is this but then if we're talking about emblematic figures right I mean if you fast forward just a little bit, you have one of what somebody who I would see as one of the absolutely most sort of richly emblematic figures of British life in my lifetime, a British kind of political and cultural life. And that is Lord Botham of Brexit.
过早地秃顶，跑步时双脚外八字。而你把他们与这些家伙进行比较——这些家伙就像……英格兰队看到他们时肯定会想：“这都是些什么人啊？”但话说回来，如果我们谈论的是具有象征意义的人物，对吧？我的意思是，如果你把时间稍微快进一点点，你就会遇到一个我认为是我有生之年英国生活中最具丰富象征意义的人物之一，一个英国政治和文化生活中的标志性人物。那就是脱欧勋爵波瑟姆（Lord Botham of Brexit）。
So Ian Botham, working class conservative, Thatcherite. And then later on, a hugely outspoken Eurosceptic. And it was going to be James Bond, wasn't he, Dominic? It was going to be James Bond. And a personification of a kind of Georgian Englishness that I think has reasserted itself in the last few decades. Also, let us say, in fairness to Lord Botham of Brexit, Viv Richard's best friend.
所以伊恩·博瑟姆，工人阶级的保守派，撒切尔主义者。后来，他成了一个直言不讳的欧洲怀疑论者。多米尼克，他本来要演詹姆斯·邦德的，对吧？他本来要演詹姆斯·邦德的。他是某种格鲁吉亚式英国性的化身，我认为这种英国性在过去几十年里已经重新确立了地位。另外，为了对“脱欧勋爵”博瑟姆保持公正，我们也得说，他是维夫·理查兹最好的朋友。
Yeah, exactly. Which is really interesting. And early teammate. They famously shared a flat together. So a sort of populist hero, basically. A populist hero who comes along and never defeats the West Indies, in fairness. West Indies are too good even for both of them. Well, he always fails against them.
对，确实如此。这真的很有趣。而且他们早年是队友。他们著名的合租过一套公寓。所以，基本上他是一个民粹主义英雄。一个出现的民粹主义英雄，不过说实话，他从未战胜过西印度群岛。西印度群岛对他们两个来说都太强了。嗯，他对上西印度群岛时总是表现不佳。
He can never do anything against them. But he does slay Australia and he does reassert English dominance in the ashes, which makes him into this folk hero. Yeah. So, John, I mean, I think I think it's the kind of the friendship between Botham and Richards, England's greatest, West Indies greatest batsman, is a reminder that cricket can, you know, it's not just about kind of racial oppression. No, I mean, it's not just about kind of um racial oppression no i mean it's about friendship however i mean it is in in against the backdrop of kind of recent scandals involving racism in accusations of racism at yorkshire in particular um with south asian players uh we should i think we should look at the role that cricket plays in because we're running out of time we should look at the role that cricket plays in, because we're running out of time, we should look at the role that cricket has played in India,
他从来拿他们没办法。但他击溃了澳大利亚，并在灰烬杯中重塑了英格兰的统治地位，这使他成为了一个民间英雄。所以，约翰，我的意思是，我认为博瑟姆和理查兹之间的友谊——英国最伟大的球员与西印度群岛最伟大的击球手——提醒我们，板球，你知道的，它不仅仅关于种族压迫。不，我的意思是不仅仅是关于种族压迫，不，我的意思是它是关于友谊的，然而，鉴于约克郡特别是针对南亚球员的种族主义指控等近期丑闻背景，我认为我们应该审视板球在——因为我们的时间不多了——我们应该审视板球在……因为我们的时间不多了，我们应该审视板球在印度所扮演的角色，
in Pakistan, and perhaps the role that it plays within racial dynamics in England now. Because basically, cricket now is fundamentally an Indian sport rather than an English one. Would you say that's an exaggeration? Oh, no, not at all. Yeah, India is the heart of the game now. It's the financial centre of the game.
在巴基斯坦，以及它现在在英国的种族动态中所扮演的角色。因为基本上，现在的板球从根本上说是一项印度运动，而不是一项英国运动。你会觉得这是一种夸张吗？哦，不，一点也不。对，印度现在是这项运动的心脏。它是这项运动的金融中心。
Cultural centre. But it's also where the soul of the game is because the population is so obsessed with cricket in a way that we're not in England and increasingly they're not in the West Indies anymore. The Australians are, but obviously they're a much smaller population. So no no India is
文化中心。但这也是这项运动的灵魂所在，因为民众对板球的痴迷程度是我们英国所没有的，而且西印度群岛也越来越不复存在了。澳大利亚人有这种热情，但显然他们的人口要少得多。所以不，不，印度是
where the soul of the game is now There was a question, I can't actually see it on the list we've got but somebody asked a question, do you think that India against Pakistan in cricket is the biggest sporting fixture in the world? I do, well one thing I would mention really quickly before that
现在这项运动的灵魂所在。有一个问题，我实际上在我们列出的清单上找不到它，但有人问了一个问题，你认为印度对阵巴基斯坦的板球比赛是世界上规模最大的体育赛事吗？我是这么认为的，不过在这之前我得快速提一件事
I know we haven't got loads of time but it was a game again that I was at as a, as a young, a young lad. And it was the 1983 world cup final. Which they've just made a film about. They have just made a film about, which was India versus West Indies.
我知道我们没有太多时间，但这也是一场我年轻时去现场看过的比赛。那是1983年的世界杯决赛。他们刚为这拍了一部电影。他们刚为这拍了一部电影，就是印度对阵西印度群岛。
And this was the moment of which, if you, if you were saying there was a moment at which India began to emerge as the center of the game that we're talking about, it was at this game when as game when, as massive underdogs, they defeated West Indies, who had been at that point twice champions. And there was a tremendously symbolic moment when Kapil Dev, the Indian captain, caught out Viv Richards from a high,
这就是那个时刻，如果你说有一个时刻，印度开始显现出成为我们所谈论的这项运动的中心，那就是在这场比赛中，作为绝对不被看好的一方，他们击败了西印度群岛，而西印度群岛在当时已经是两次冠军。这是一个极具象征意义的时刻，当时印度队长卡皮尔·德夫高高跃起，
steepling catch and the whole of Lour's holding its breath as this ball falls to earth. And Capple holds the catch and dismisses the great Richards. And this is the moment at which India comes out. A new India is born. Well, before then, there's no doubt and there is no doubt. I don't know how to say this in the right way, really. There was a kind of cultural cringe in India, a kind of feeling amongst Indians that they were somehow beneath still the hand of empire. And this was a moment,
接住了维夫·理查兹高高飞向空中的击球，随着这个球下落，罗德球场的所有人都屏住了呼吸。卡皮尔接住了球，淘汰了伟大的理查兹。这就是印度崛起的时刻。一个新的印度诞生了。嗯，在那之前，毫无疑问，而且毫无疑问。我不知道该怎么正确地表达这一点，真的。印度有一种文化自卑感，印度人有一种感觉，他们似乎仍然在帝国的手掌之下。而这是一个时刻，
I think, when actually that began to lift and they got underneath chapel. They all stood up, their chests puffed out, and they began to think, hang on, you know, we're a serious cricket team here, we're a serious force. And that's the moment, that's the moment it happens. And it starts to build and build. And, you know, obviously, India-Pakistan is always going to be a ferocious rivalry. The Pakistan come along in 1992 and win the World Cup. And that becomes a moment for them under Imran Khan,
我想，当时这种感觉开始消散，他们挺直了腰板。他们都站了起来，挺起胸膛，开始心想，等等，你知道，我们这里是一支严肃的板球队伍，我们是一股严肃的力量。这就是那个时刻，事情发生的时刻。它开始不断累积。而且，你知道，印度对阵巴基斯坦注定是一个极其激烈的对决。巴基斯坦在1992年来到这里并赢得了世界杯。在伊姆兰·汗的带领下，这成为了他们的一个高光时刻，
who is now the president of Pakistan, was the captain of the Pakistan cricket team. So you can probably see how important the link is between cricket and the rest of society in Pakistan. But the India-Pakistan relationship is always played out under India's power. So India, for example, now has the most famous cricket league in the world, which is called the Indian Premier League. And it doesn't allow Pakistani players in it.
他现在是巴基斯坦总统，曾任巴基斯坦板球队队长。所以你大概能看出板球与巴基斯坦其余社会之间的联系有多么重要。但印巴关系总是在印度的势力之下展开。例如，印度现在拥有世界上最著名的板球联赛，叫做印度超级联赛（IPL）。而且它不允许巴基斯坦球员参加。
That's the one nation they don't allow. But that's why when India meet Pakistan in international cricket contests, that's why it's so huge, isn't it? And why in the recent World Cup when Pakistan beat India, actually crushed India. It was such a, you know, there was glee around the world because everyone likes to see the, you know, the bully get a black eye. And that was what Pakistan inflicted. But yeah, I mean, there are, you know, we could have another three hours on why Pakistan and India is such a contest, but yes, it is.
那是唯一被禁止的国家。但这就是为什么当印度在国际板球比赛中遇到巴基斯坦时，比赛会如此轰动，对吧？为什么在最近的世界杯上，当巴基斯坦击败印度、甚至可以说彻底击溃印度时，全世界都为此欢欣鼓舞，因为每个人都喜欢看到恶霸挨揍。这就是巴基斯坦所造成的局面。但是，是的，我的意思是，我们还可以花另外三个小时来讨论为什么巴基斯坦和印度的对决会如此激烈，但事实确实如此。
Well, maybe we should save that for later then. We definitely should um yeah uh john i mean one one final question um i mean we've been talking about kind of international cricket professional cricket uh the great stars of cricket but i mean you know cricket continues to be played uh by amateurs as well oh no for god's sake. It does. And I wonder, is there maybe a particular innings, perhaps even a particular shot played by an amateur player that has a kind of historic resonance? Think very carefully about the answers that the listeners will want to hear.
好吧，也许我们应该把这个留到以后再聊。我们绝对应该……嗯……约翰，我的最后一个问题，我的意思是，我们一直在谈论国际板球、职业板球、板球巨星，但你知道，业余爱好者们也一直在打板球……哦，天哪，确实如此。我想知道，是不是可能有一场特殊的比赛，甚至可能是由一个业余球员打出的某种特定击球，带有某种历史共鸣？请仔细考虑听众们希望听到的答案。
A mythological resonance. You see, this has so come to infect my mind so often. I mean, I would say that, yeah, amateur cricket. Let's first of all, a really quick analogy. If you imagine an iceberg that's sort of 10% above the surface of the water, the 10%, that's the professional game. The 90% under the water is guys like us who like to play, guys and girls who like to play at the weekend
一种神话般的共鸣。你看，这已经如此频繁地侵蚀了我的大脑。我的意思是，我可以说，是的，业余板球。首先，我们打个非常简单的比方。如果你想象一座冰山，大约有10%露出水面，这10%就是职业比赛。水面下那90%就像我们这些喜欢打球的人，喜欢在周末打球的男男女女，
and play amateur cricket very badly. In the context of playing amateur cricket incredibly badly, you can still have triumph and disaster. Can you think of one? Maybe it's been photographed. And really, this is a tale of the social media age, I think, in that Tom's one great moment as a batsman. Well, one moment.
而且业余板球打得非常烂。在打得极其糟糕的业余板球背景下，你仍然可以体验到胜利与灾难。你能想出一个例子吗？也许它被拍下来了。这其实是一个社交媒体时代的故事，我认为，汤姆作为击球手唯一的高光时刻。好吧，高光时刻。
I think great moment is probably a bit much, isn't it? Dominic, you didn't remember cricket. But, you know, you talk about symbolic resonance, Dominic. We're talking about the playing fields of Eton. I mean, where else, if you were going to strike the one shot of your life, So we should explain, shouldn't we, to listeners, that this is, I hit a six, and a six is where you hit the ball so hard, so well, so luckily, that it goes over the kind of boundary rope,
我想说“高光时刻”可能有点过头了，对吧？多米尼克，你根本不记得板球了。但是，你知道的，你谈到了象征共鸣，多米尼克。我们在谈论伊顿公学的运动场。我的意思是，如果你要打出生命中的那一球，除了这里还能在哪里？所以我们应该向听众解释，对吧，我击出了一记六分打，六分打就是你把球打得如此之用力、如此之好、如此幸运，以至于它飞过了边界绳，
which contains the which contains the cricket pitch i was thinking about it's when i was toying with how to introduce this podcast and i went with my sir henry newbolt power yes the alternative which i had tracked down this morning was one of the grey friar school stories in which by a stroke of extraordinary chance billy bunter the fat owl of the remove, hits a six. And I thought, I won't read that out because that's a bit mean to Tom to compare him to Billy Bunter. No, not at all. But now I wish I had.
那根标志着……那根标志着板球场的边界绳。我在想……当我琢磨着该如何介绍这个播客时，我最终采用了亨利·纽博尔特爵士的诗句。是的，我今天早上查到的另一个备选项是《格雷弗莱尔学校故事》，其中写到胖猫头鹰比利·本特通过一记极其走运的击球打出了一个六分。我想，我还是别读出来了，因为拿汤姆和比利·本特相比对汤姆有点太刻薄了。不，一点也不。但现在我希望我当时读了。
No, not at all. Because the point is, it's not just that I hit it, but that it was photographed. And listeners who want to know this, I will make sure to include it on my Twitter feed. The narcissism of the Instagram age. That's exactly what it is. It's me playing the game, playing up, playing up and playing the game. As you have done, John, can't thank you enough. I think it is time to...
不，一点也不。因为关键在于，不仅仅是我打出了那一球，而是它被拍了下来。想要知道这一点的听众，我一定会确保把它发到我的推特上。Instagram时代的自恋。这就是它的本质。这就是我打球、表现自己、在场上挥洒自如的样子。正如你所做的那样，约翰，非常感谢你。我想是时候……
On that bombshell. Draw stumps, retire the team. Take the bails. Retire to the pub. Thanks very much, everyone um thank you uh enjoy the ashes if you like cricket uh i hope that some of this has made sense if you don't goodbye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
带着这个重磅消息，收局退场，全队退役。收起三柱门。去酒吧庆祝一下吧。非常感谢大家。谢谢，如果你喜欢板球的话，请好好享受灰烬杯吧。希望这些内容对你有所帮助，如果没有的话，再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告版内容
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。